two hello everybody it's Monday it is uh
October
16th it is
sunny it is
nice it is La it's a rainy day out here
in Los
Angeles I have hair
again rub it in looking at my buzzed
head mhm why is this seems too pointy
doesn't it like yeah I mean I thought
your perfect hairline was just a
straight line across your forehead but
you seem to have a bit of a Widows Peak
going on I wouldn't say a straight line
that's like weird DJ cow
business but but I don't know it's just
a little surprising to see don't you
guys think like
shocking might have to look into plugs
yeah anyway thank you everybody uh book
you a flight to Turkey right now thank
you
yes thank you everybody for being here
nice to see you that anybody's here
after uh Friday in the weekend there are
people here right cuz I don't have the
stream
open you mean fans of the H3 podcast
yeah yeah they're uh they're our fans
they're they're watching the show right
now okay good I wasn't sure if they'd be
here I am our biggest fan how's
everybody's weekend I spent the majority
of it sick but I'm better today sound
great today today was I yesterday I was
starting to feel better and today it
seems to be gone very good Dan y sick
anyone else got anything they want to uh
share with the class before I anyone uh
I signed on a new apartment me
Lena let's go dude congratulations
[Music]
thank
yeah anyways I could remember if we
talked about it or not no we didn't okay
I said something uh about a that may be
compromising ab's address all right
Sniper Wolf not it was a a minor
infraction but out of abundance of
caution right we yeah but that
appreciate that people were telling me
not to tell you my new address so that
you don't Le it on a Tuesday I know
where you live it's not Tuesday I know
where you
live you know but uh AB was saying they
I don't know how much got cut off but he
got a new spot it's bigger people
congratulating AB so I think they they
got yes they got the news
congratulations thank you happy for you
thank
you appreciate that is that new record
actually I think we had one even earlier
than that a couple weeks ago the bottom
right off the gate once yeah we had our
earlier one yeah yeah yeah yeah we have
we've we've done worse yeah eventually
because it happens retroactively you'll
say something literally in the first 5
seconds and the show will just open with
the button screen we haven't done that
yet yeah but close I think the first the
worst one was pretty dang close didn't
you literally hit the buttom right as we
and you said what happens if I do this
and you did it maybe I don't remember I
think that happened well
anyway smash that button thanks for
being here obviously I don't know anyone
that's been
following my
journey since Thursday when we had the
uh I thought we had a really nice
episode of leftovers actually and I will
say just to be totally I
guess let's let's let's go from the a
higher view on all
thisas is that the
um the comments on the podcast that we
did were are are terrific and people
showed a lot of
appreciation for the honest of the
conversation and the kind of the you
know different perspectives that we we
we took I like one of the top comments
was that we both exist in each other's
blind spots which I thought was really
kind of a ni saw that one way to look at
it different perspectives yeah so Gary
ass podcast yes so oh and by the way
huge hit was turning the chat off on
leftovers which I pretty sure we that
needs to be a consistent
now you
know that was that was so important man
but even without that it it did descend
into some pretty nasty stuff
uh you
know we were talking about it in our
group chat a lot of us have been getting
this Abu had mentioned it to me the
expectations that people on both sides
have have on any of us to to express
ourselves in the exact same way that
they like they expect or that like
silence is you know I don't know but
like ela's getting a ton of [__] hate
from
Israelis who are
like dude Ela has a friend who told her
because she's not speaking up more she
has the
blood of the of the dead the dead uh
Israelis on our hands
Jesus that's psychotic it is psych it is
psychotic that's a psychotic thing to
say um you're getting it Zach I've
gotten a couple messages
yeah maybe you don't want to talk you
don't have to no I'll talk about it I
mean listen i' I've fought for
Palestinian rights for a long time since
I you know since I was in college I was
uh there was a big wall of flags in
University Center at University of
Michigan Dearborn and they didn't have
Palestine on on there and I was the one
that fought to get Palestine put on
there there in um you know clearly I
stand with Palestine and I and I feel
for the innocent people in Israel as
well but yeah I'm just I'm terrified to
comment on it because if I say something
wrong or if I even if I'm defending
Palestina or whatever side I'm defending
if I don't say it in the correct way I'm
afraid I'm going to get [__] there's
always someone there's always something
that you didn't say perfectly yeah
that will be twisted into the most
heinous interpretation of what you could
possibly dream to
take and
um I told I'll just be I told Eli don't
say anything because it doesn't matter
what you
say either side is going to dog pile on
you and for example ELO posted
um did I not link that the the the thing
that Ela restored
s is that in the dock I don't know if I
saw it but I think I could find it eler
reposted
um the
art of an Israeli artist here here's one
of
them so the first one she posted was
this it's it's Netanyahu with blood on
his hands the caption says something
like um the adult in charge or something
mhm so that was the first post and the
second post here here's the second was
this which depicts a really you know
horrific scene I think the art is
interesting just from the perspective of
almost like a like a child of which
there was a lot
there and it says we do not forgive we
do not forget in Hebrew and it's
pointing to the picture of of Netanyahu
who has blood on his hands in that
photo
and so the immediate reaction was um
people started
just
going especially on our subreddit and
just saying like the most heinous things
about Ela that she's like I mean you
could imagine I don't want to repeat and
so I had to put out this [__]
statement being like this this is just a
lot of what's been happening I don't
know if you
have do I have that statement that I put
out uh I have it you like me to pull it
up one sec
uh wait this is part two right yeah that
was
part thank you R Kelly thank you AB or
that's awesome anyway Kelly has R Kelly
weighed in on this situation at all I
just said dumb
[__] you should at least [__]
understand what it is you're looking at
before you call someone
like a
murderer a genocidal
Maniac I'm just saying like before you
accuse
someone of being a genocidal
murderer you should at least spend one
second trying to understand what the
[__] it actually
says it was lit here here it is it was
literally a post that was expressing
from the Israeli
perspective rage the government's
failure and blaming this all on the
government Netanyahu who we all hate by
the
way said Dear dumb [__] going after El
for this post it literally says we do
not forgive and we do not forget while
pointing out natano really rage at the
government he has blood on his hands you
know and there's there so I don't know
what it is but there's just a lot of
people who
were
um just being really uncharitable to me
and ELO just nasty nasty nasty nasty
stuff which is disappointing because I
felt like I feel like I'm genuinely
trying
to keep my mind open and learn and like
understand the Palestinian
perspective and I and I feel like I am
doing that I feel like I am I am
learning more mhm and becoming
more
empathetic but um I genuinely feel that
there's just way too many people that
see like Israelis equal
Evil isra all all Israelis equal
settlers all Israelis equal
settlers and you know when you when you
say anyway that that's whatever that's a
whole different conversation
but
um I was was just there was one tweet I
saw and this isn't the first time I saw
it
but I saw someone post it and it was
getting lots of likes and that you know
the the beautiful irony of this is so
it's a video a cartoon somebody
created who put a lot of [__] effort
into making a cartoon of ela and IDF
uniform with a automatic
weapon and you know she's
all she's got like that kind of Nazi
Jewish propaganda face and she's just
killing kids she's just mowing down his
Palestinian
babies and what's F what's kind of I
don't know it's I definitely not funny I
don't know what it is you guys tell me I
know that that [__] was made by Nazis
like literal Nazis MH and the people who
I saw who were tweeting it this
time were leftist mhm so I saw Nazis and
left left us clapping hands
together to
say you know [__] [__] Israel we agree
on that let's clap it up
brother and that was a weird uh that was
a weird feeling for me and
I was in a pretty bad shape and
um so I I I've been trying to erase
Twitter I've been trying all weekend you
do you guys know how and by the way I I
I can't thank you
I can't deactivate my account because it
makes my handle open which is insane
obviously that that would be insane to
let some to let to let somebody else
grab it you
know so that's not an option so I was
trying to figure out ways to just erase
all my tweets all my
likes and it is so [__] hard dude I
was trying all week and it was really
upsetting me because I just needed to
get out of there
I did finally figure out a way to um I
guess you can download your Twitter data
which you have to wait 24 hours for and
then I bought some software that I could
put the Twitter data in and it seems
like just right
now like just right before we started
the show it looks like all my tweets
were successfully
erased which is nice that that was that
was driving me crazy um and then the
next thing is I just want to erase all
my likes which I guess is a there's like
30,000 of them it's like God damn delete
30 [__] so it's a pretty Monumental
task I guess so once once the uh tweets
and likes are gone and it's
burned I'm going to rase the app hell
yeah let's [__] go dude byebye to all
the psychos there welcome back to
threads
baby maybe I'll join threads I did say
I'm a
threadhead
um yeah the one thing I will say though
and again because it's important to look
at this from a high up
perspective that while a lot of leftists
were um
very
cruel and they're uh assessment of me
and
Ela that there was something that took
place
um there was actually I guess in the uh
Arabic or the Muslim Community there was
um a clip of me talking about you know
how I was affected seeing some of the
things that were coming out of
Gaza and um they were it was getting
shared a lot and social media of people
saying like oh here thanks AB yeah I'm
getting [__] on in Dearborn but you're a
goddamn
hero that's even my aunt sent it to me
she's like he made me cry with this I
was like that's nice just yeah I think
that's that's very important to keep in
mind Ethan is that uh and that's why
yeah I I applaud you deleting Twitter
get off of that [__] because it's just
it's just brain poison and it can rat
hole it's designed for pylons you know
it is literally designed for that and um
and you're not really getting a clear
picture of uh of the community and I
think uh as evidenced by that I mean I
think a lot of ordinary people if they
heard your position and and as evidenced
by this clip that's gone viral in ab's
Hometown I think um and people
understand that your heart's in the
right
place they said um American Israeli
content creator Ethan Klein broke down
while speaking about Palestine
Palestinians killed by Israeli air
strikes in Gaza Klein condemned the
Israeli Siege of Gaza while Co hosting
the leftovers podcast on Thursday with
American Turkish polit political
commentator Hassan
[__] um the
comments still have uh Humanity in him
thank God proof you can be Jewish and
Israeli and have a good
heart
um beautiful display of humanity
compassion and love this is the only
thing to fix a broken world it's great
it's great
and
so I'm I'm glad that that happened
because it helped me a lot
yeah
[Music]
I mean the people on Twitter it's like
these people think they're activists but
they really don't care
about they really don't care about doing
anything meaningful because going on
Twitter and you know spreading spreading
really
nasty propaganda or calling someone like
me a [__] apar tie genocidal maniac
and all that stuff and retweeting
cartoons of ela
murdering literal Neo naazi Cartoons by
the way that's I mean isn't that
something no yeah I mean the irony of
that was not lost on
me makes you I don't know makes me it
makes
me but again the the beautiful thing was
was that this whole AB sent it to me and
then I guess a lot of people were seeing
it and that that to me was very nice
that to me was was very meaningful and
it you know it really did it says a lot
because like the reaction that uh I saw
people having to that was really simply
a reaction to somebody in Israeli
American or even somebody on
the cuz I listen I'm not I'm fully aware
that the media in
America especially and I think in most
Western countries right now are like
vastly vastly on the side of
Israel are like uncritically supportive
of
Israel um this is a poll and politicians
especially which is the worst part who
are just like enabling the
worst things that Israel is doing saw
this on uh NPR this morning
so just to just to put the the pylon in
perspective
um this is important to to remember P
publicly supports Israel is the like
teal column yes so overall 65% support
Israel gray is is UN and and then the
yellow which is what number is that
eight eight% they they criticize Israel
now
that's that as a whole is is insane I
mean 8% CR criticize Israel that that's
crazy I mean yeah that that that we
gotta get those numbers up so like I
want to you know bear in mind again I'm
trying to look at all this from the high
high
level is at the end of the day how
however much you'll hear
me trying to speak up for the Israeli
perspective and talking about a lot of
the
propaganda that I see against Israelis
and Jews and the kind of radical
language that I'm seeing that I think is
dangerous I want to make it very clear
that I
understand that looking at this
poll the big problem is Israel okay and
the and the uncritical support that
people have for it but at the same time
I do think it's important
to
to convey Israelis as complex human
beings and not caricatures of gen that
they're all genocidal
monsters cuz that's not productive at
all like how can you how can you say
that
you're that you want peace that you want
change that you're an activist meaning
that you know you're you're activating
for change you're you can't achieve that
by looking at the enemy quote unquote
enemy
as one-dimensional people they're com
there there's such a huge diversity of
people in Israel and by the way right
now the majority of them [__] hate
the government and blame the government
I'll have I'll also say
that I mean every everything that's
happening
now is the direct
actions of
a extremely conservative
violent genocidal
government that was made by Benjamin
Netanyahu out of desperation to hold on
to power he made a coalition with
basically Israeli Nazis I mean I don't
they're they're like fascists I mean
that's what they're trying to do and
what's interesting is right before this
there was massive protests in Israel
because Netanyahu and his
fascist party was trying to
um basically uh declaw the judicial
system to
to put any meaningful checks on the
executive branch so they were doing
trying to do a massive power grab which
is definitely a symptom of a fascist
government and there was massive protest
in Israel against that including a huge
percentage of IDF members who refuse to
report to duty like 20% or something who
refus to report to duty because of their
efforts
to declaw the the dud
D
judicial Judicial
System
Ben is that for is that for BB are we in
BB's walls that's pretty good Ben Ben
Ben that is Benjamin
net I'm inside your walls B oh
no
and I've been watching the news uh
heavily
and again I want to
be as supportive of possible of what the
Palestinians are going through while
also
providing what I think is an important
Israeli perspective on
things for
example a six-year-old kid was murdered
in Chicago oh my God this story is so
[__] by a CRA his crazed
landlord
who hates Muslims and Palestinians I
even I don't think he's Jewish he's just
a [__] Maniac
yeah but regardless it doesn't really
matter that's a result of the kind of
craz coverage you see in by politicians
in America and most of the media you
know it's kind of funny actually it was
posted
by I acknowledge that I oh yeah see dude
I can't it's so [__]
sad it's so sad dude this this beautiful
child and so like you
know hate crimes are up by the way for
isra for Jews
and Muslims SLP Palestinians Arabs
whatever but this was certainly
the just the worst thing that came out
of this that I saw over the
weekend I mean what the [__] who look at
this beautiful child he's
he's could you do
that genuinely don't
know can't even can't even imagine and
then like uh you know if you if
you of all the Israelis that I [__]
criticize and hate the most besides the
government are the Western settlers who
are literally
monsters over the weekend settlers
killed like 60 people in the West Bank's
families Jesus do you have that
story I don't I I saw something about it
like it's just been such a delu of
horrifying news that it's hard to even
keep up
see by the way these settlers are armed
and enabled by the
government I saw a video of a dude a a
craze
settler he was having an argument with a
a Palestinian
guy he had a rifle in his
hand a military grade
rifle and he's Israeli settlers take
advantage of Gaza chaos to attack
Palestinians in West Bank settlers and
soldiers have killed 51 Palestinians in
West Bank since Saturday at least two
Palestinian Villages have been entirely
depopulated
God I saw a video of
um I mean it's so it's a he's having an
argument with a Palestinian guy and he's
I obviously you can't tell what they're
talking about because it's filmed from
really far away but he has a military
grade rifle the Palestinian gu standing
like this the the settler charges
towards him like really aggressively the
Palestinian guy's got his hands up he's
not moving because he he's not like
hands up like surrendering he's just
trying to show that he's not threatening
him physically like I'm not trying to
I'm not trying to fight you and the guy
the settler he pushes
him and then like slowly and
deliberately lifts his rifle and shoots
him Jesus in the stomach and there's a
IDF Soldier standing right behind
him it just like waves him back to
safety cuz he behind him like you know
20 feet was a group of his friends I'm
assuming and
uh uh you know
it's you see this a lot when you see
footage of Palestinians but the way that
they C swoop in and picked them up and
carried them off for medical care was
like so routine to them you can tell
they were so fast and efficient at cting
off their friend who was
shot
um and it's you
know they're really efficient at it
because they're doing it all the
time and this guy I don't think he's
been I don't think he's been punished I
don't think he's even
been
investigated because he's doing what
they're what he's meant to be
doing also in
Gaza the Israeli government has been
telling everybody to evacuate Gaza City
which is a city of
like A.1 million 1.1 million again it's
worth
mentioning that 50% of them are under 18
40% of them are under
14 they're being uh ordered to mass
evacuate out of of Gaza City because
Israel is planning a ground
Invasion to try
to root out
Hamas and which I think is starting
today the Hamas right before I went live
I was seeing that it looks like they're
staging to to go in now I have to say
I'm I'm quite surprised that it took
this long cuz they said they were going
to go in after 24 hours and I think that
the International Community Biden has
been putting a lot of pressure on them
to ease the [__] up I hope so at least
behind the scenes publicly he is he is I
think that the other I mean there's
there's quote unquote good news but that
they opened back up the the means for
water electricity Fuel and Medical Aid
so that is coming back into Gaza from
the Egyptian border right yeah
yeah
or I don't know because the Egyptians
closed their border too so I'm not even
sure what's the where it's coming I I
don't know the logistics it might be
coming from boats I don't know it's like
AIDS no my understanding is the relief
columns are coming in from the Rafa
Crossing it's called down in okay so
anyway they're letting it back in and
they turn and Israel which controls the
utilities the water
electricity yeah that's and gas which
was turned off for like a week I think
since the day after the attack right or
within days yeah was uh
restored oh I hadn't seen that that it
was
restored yeah they I heard last night
that they opened back up the floor maybe
I haven't seen that of utilities but
again you you think
about I look at this one child and and
it breaks my heart this kid who was
murdered by this
psychotic
Maniac the one in Chicago yeah but but
then you think 40% of the 1 point or the
2 million people that live in Gaza are
under 14 that's like I you know 800,000
kids and Israel cut off
food from entering for like a week food
people were
starving I I saw people were rationing
off their food to their kids while the
parents didn't eat anything like they
literally didn't have
food it was like a frenzy trying to get
a you know a p bread from like the
bakery how [__] crazy is
that makes no sense like what what and
again
like I don't see I don't I don't even
see the defense like how do they even
defend that like how was that milit how
does
that benefit the military to cut off
food because here's the thing Hamas has
stockpiles of equipment
they are prepared for a land for a
ground invasion they have a vast network
of tunnels and they're stocked up on
that [__] so the the people who are
definitely not starving is
Hamas the Hamas theyve they're the only
people not
starving so I I don't understand the
even the military justification for
doing that and water it does just seem
like cruelty I'm um I'm not seeing
anything about them I think that they
still have all the utilities cut off on
water was definitely turned back on see
water turn uh yeah I'm seeing this one
article Israel restores water supply to
Southern Gaza to encourage evacuation of
North yeah they did that okay I think
even a couple days ago got it got
it yeah yeah that's kind of important
water water's water's pretty important
yeah so having said all
that because I want to emphasize again
that I want to look at this
all from the highest Vantage Point
possible and while fully
acknowledging
um different perspectives thank you Gary
that's Gary ve approves
[Applause]
chist I'm just listen guys I'm just
doing what Gary ve told me to do yeah
he's my now put that phone down
different perspectives oh and you you're
getting rid of Twitter you listen oh
perspectives you've been silenced I've
been
silenced oh your screen is frozen Dan
yeah I see that is that
okay and so while fully while fully
fully acknowledging the plight of
Palestinians under the government of
Israel under the violence that's been on
act oh yeah the other thing I didn't say
is that a caravan was apparently bombed
while they were going south like the
army told them to do 70 people died
again 40% of those are kids whenever you
hear people dying 40% are
kids uh it's terrifying it really is
it's
horrible you see what's going on at the
White House today what I actually just
saw it right before we went live uh let
me pull it up uh basically there's a
huge demonstration by an American Jewish
group outside the White House uh calling
for
ceasefire oh I've seen yeah that's nice
I've seen I mean there's a lot of out
there look there's a lot of Jews out
there Jews in particular American Jews
um or just non-israeli Jews I guess I
should say there are a lot of Israeli
Jews as well
sure I mean naturally here in the states
it's going to be American Jews primarily
oh there's a lot of crazy ass Israel
supporters here in America too like damn
I mean Hamas was saying like the media
coverage in Israel is way more nuanced
even than our conservative coverage
here right right yeah no and I've
continued to see that it's shocking how
which again is something that people
need to bear in mind when they look at
Israelis as
one-dimensional just people that hate
Arabs and want to kill them is that the
Israeli media has long been very
critical
even when I lived there these these
newspapers like haritz and
um what's the there's the J post which I
don't think is super liberal but the
haritz in particular has always been
extremely critical
of of what Israel is doing
uh when the war crimes are happening and
haritz is one of the most popular papers
in
Israel so I'm just telling you
guys that we need to view these people
all as complex three-dimensional
beings so again the reason I say all
that not the reason but now that I've
said all that
about what's happening in Gaza and the
Westbank frankly um or just Palestinians
in
general cuz I want people to bear in
mind that they
are the victims okay they are the ones
being self they're the ones that are
being you know put in a
ghetto and being rounded up and [__]
with and murdered okay so fully
acknowledging that but then here's where
people lose my their mind is that when I
want to talk about Israelis as human
beings they don't want to [__] hear
it
there was some stuff I saw that was just
so disturbing over the weekend
um let me
see this
one
now this clip
is I think she is a Hassan mod I think
just like
froan
and
so Hassan is not associated with them
this again I don't say that to put blame
on him but these are a lot of the people
that are watching leftovers episodes and
so anyway here here's her take and then
we'll I'll respond to
it the conscription is mandatory but you
can go to jail for like a couple months
if you refuse to join there have been
lots of people who have protested their
government by doing so and I get that
that's a big sacrifice to ask of the
Israeli people that live there
but I I'm just not I'm just personally
not a fan of
of you know I had to do what I was
forced to do it I feel like you start
getting really close to like nurg trial
type [__] there so she so she's trying
to compare anyone drafted into the IDF
mandatory conscription to being a
[__]
Nazi
now if if you need an update on the
nberg
trials and I'm not going to I'm not
going to be super I'm not I'm going to
try I'm not going to be super mean okay
I'm I'm going to be charitable to her
but I just want to talk about this point
okay
um the nberg trials was held by the
Allies after World War II ended to
charge prominent Nazis with war crimes
it was like 20
people they were Admirals SS
officers people that had an active role
and Exterminating Jewish people 20 of
them
um so comparing someone who's
conscripted to the IDF as a [__] Nazi
is pretty rich and let me tell you what
IDF is not like Western armies as we
understand it the IDF is ingrained into
the culture the fabric of society there
because it's mandatory because it's
conscription because it's so large the
IDF does so many different has so many
different roles in society there's so
many different jobs that you can have in
the
IDF
um also like people want to say this
about Eli I mean she served in the IDF
like at this point God it must have been
like 15 20 20 years ago so
like it's
different if you're being drafted right
now and you're like I don't want to go I
mean okay I get that but like you can't
look at anyone who's in the IDF and say
nberg trial that's that's that's [__]
up I
mean okay I'm going to try and be
charitable to her position here and push
back a little bit um I think that that's
that's probably a poor analogy to draw
because of the historical association
with Nazis and extermination Jews I
think what she's trying to say is that
the excuse of just following orders has
been found to not be sufficient to
people now now but that's in reference
to
specific uh 20 people were tried in the
nberg approximately I don't know the
exact number right following orders I
mean that's not it's just not a fair
characterization to say the it's not no
the vast majority of people in the IDF
are not on the front line killing people
the the majority people it's a small
percent of the IDF that's even on the
front line taking on combat I would say
and so this this notion that every IDF
person is
um is uh just just following orders it
it it dehumanizes
them yeah me it dehumanizes them and
I'll say this it makes it makes it sound
like they're all valid targets of
terrorism it's this one attitude that I
have a problem with is saying like every
Israeli is a
settler because if that's the case
settler
babies right then everybody's fair game
to uh War Terror and violence that's
what this does if you're in the IDF
which is basically 99% of all
Israelis and I'll let you know although
I don't think this girl cares but just
to explain you're 18 when you join the
IDF you're not a woke you're you're not
mentally developed like I you know
that's more along the lines of my
thinking that you have I
mean this
systematic problem of mass conscription
and Universal conscription I mean the
military
does I mean even if you're even if
you're not on the front lines like you
said or somebody's like a secretary like
Eli you can argue that you're still a
part of the machine and contributing to
these acts however I mean this is a
society that you are indoctrinated into
from a very young age and I think a lot
of
us we I think everyone would like to
think that they would have that attitude
that they're a 17-year-old kid and that
they would have the moral character to
say no and to go to jail and to be
ostracized by their peers as a result
and I would like to think that if I was
in that position I would do that but how
can I really say that and how can
anybody really say that without living
listen Liv like listen if you don't join
the military in Israel You're basically
a social outcast you Pro you have you
can't even find work afterward right
there's an you're disowned you're
shunned by your family terrible and and
is a problem and and and speaks to kind
of the the sickness that's going on in
that Society um but I don't know it to
to put that on to put that on a bunch of
teenagers that likely don't know anym I
don't
know they're 18 years old they don't
have [__] any experience in the world
okay their only uh experience growing up
has been a lot of propag standed that
you know I myself heard when I was
living
there
um and so I'm sorry
but and that the by the way the IDF is
not a monolith there there's such a huge
swath of types of different people
because like I said it's not like how we
understand the
military in America or other Western
countries I don't know it's everybody
body everybody it's part and by the way
this besides you know uh what's
happening with Palestinians there are
legitimate security issues and
legitimate jobs that the the Army does
have to do not just militarily for the
country so people have this civic duty
the Civic expectation to undergo
this and so to to I to them all like
nberg trials it's just again it's it's
the
dehumanization we're not achieving
anything when we look at them all like
Nazi war criminals okay how the [__] are
you ever going to achieve any kind of
understanding or
peace as a leftist
activist if you're going to just dismiss
all
Israelis 99% of them who've been in the
IDF
as nurmberg
nazzis one-dimensional hateful cowards
even uh they're all
cowards and she I love how she's like
yeah you can go to jail for a couple
months I don't think she has any idea
what she's talking
about what's the what's the punishment
for not going to the Army I know you go
to jail I don't know for how long it's a
long I think it's longer than months I
thought it was a CP I think it's a
couple years but I look at yeah it's
couple years um it's not a good it's not
a good time and like dude at least be
honest don't be like oh yeah you go
there for a couple weeks it's no big
deal let's see uh not a good it's not a
good refusal to serve
IDF
Ben
yeah um 90 days I mean that is just
three months 90 days is
uh I'm trying to find a better Source
here did you ask chat gbt I did not ask
chat gbt ask I was looking for a for a
direct source here here's an a Read's uh
article about it gp's
up all right let's see what chat TBC
says let's see uh those who dodg the
draft without exemption can face
consequences criminal penalties agion of
military service is a criminal offense
under Israeli law those who are found
guilty can face prison the duration can
vary based on individual circumstances
and it's at the discretion of a military
Court civil penties in add in addition
to potential jail time individual who
evade the draft might also encounter
civil penalties they might be denied
certain government benefits or job
opportunities
yeah social stigma this is an illegal
penalty but it's worth noting that
serving in the IDF is a significant
right of passage in Israeli Society
those who evad did you say that you can
lose social like you can lose like uh
welfare and stuff
yeah yeah you become like an you become
a total Outcast service guarantees
citizenship right from Starship Troopers
it's like it's literally that I don't
know about like removing yeah they make
your life hell they do they make your
life hell H uh limitation on
travel oh wait here the social stigma is
worth noting that the IDF is a
significant right of passage in Israeli
Society the thing is kids don't go off
to college like they do here like
that's go off to college and you're on
your own in Israel it's the
Army it it is such a part of the culture
there when you finish high school you go
to the Army and that's
your that's your coming of
yeah exactly that's how they do that
crazy those who evade service might face
social stigma or be viewed less
favorable by certain segments of the
population limitations on travel draft
Dodgers might find their ability to
travel outside of Israel is limited as
they can be arrested upon their
return there are exemptions this part is
the [__] worst the religious folks
don't have to serve is that
crazy
crazy like we're they're for forg them
to fight for these these pieces of [__]
that won't even fight themselves medical
or psychological examinations stuff like
that can get you Exempted so if you're
Orthodox hidic Jew you don't have to go
into the IDF there was some no there are
religious Exceptions there was a really
weird rule because the the
religious Orthodox in Israel although
it's not a huge percent of the
population it is a powerful
one because everybody's always trying to
uh get them involved in their Co
Coalition and of course they're super
conservative and they're part of uh
netanyahu's
Coalition but they carved out at one
point this [__] idea that their
service to the state is they're just
stud studying the Bible and that's just
says is important they get an exemption
so they can study the
Torah crazy right
right so
again the purpose of me talking about
this clip and all this is not I'm not
trying to malign
her I understand where she's coming from
right it's easy to you know what I
totally understand where she's coming
from it's easy to look at it and be like
you know just don't join the
IDF but I want to
explain how much more complicated it is
than that
lest leftist look at all Israelis
as fair
game in the war of
extermination and let me ask you this I
mean
listen a lot of the leftists that I've
been listening to and hearing about that
I've talked
about they say that every Israeli is a
occupier and they deserve anything that
happens to them in the revolution and so
if you look at every Israeli as an
occupier what what exactly is your plan
for working this out in the end so we we
we have this idea of achieving peace
right so I ask those of
you who proudly say all Israelis are
occupiers
and valid targets for the Freedom
Fighters of
Hamas I ask this very simple
question what happens to
Israel
when I guess they have they want like
all the surrounding Arab countries to
group up and invade I don't know I think
that's that's their hope what happens to
all of these quote settlers the 5 six
million uh
Israelis who are all fair
game you see what I'm
saying
like we can't use the genocide happening
in
Gaza to
justify potentially another
one we have to be
morally we have to be Mor Al
consistent we have to be against
violence of
civilians and the freedom of people
everywhere even if you [__] hate them
a lot of these people hate Israel and
Israelis you you you too quick to become
the monster that that you're
condemning and I'm not saying that she's
doing this I'm just saying I
see the path that they're
walking and where it's leading to that
was just one example I didn't like I
didn't like that but you know again no
hate to her I'm just trying to ex uh
explain my perspective on
this um the next thing this one was
really really [__] up
man and the reason I I show this one is
just the amount of Engagement
and skeptic skepticism that it
got here is I don't even know if I can
show
this can you can you do one where it's
blurred out or actually I don't know
it's important to show for the context
though uh you talking about this one
there's no body there's just blood in it
uh YouTu I mean if you're concerned
about that I'm pretty sure YouTube will
they
demonetize you can just describe it so
uh this was a photo released oh thank
you
AB mhm oh AB with the [__] AB with
for the win so here here's the photo
okay it's cropped because the
bottom depicts a really bloody scene of
dried
blood and then next to it is a coloring
book also covered in blood except
there's splatters of pink on the paper
and so the fine people of Twitter who
are now all forensic blood splatter
experts have
all agreed that this photo is fake the
blood on the book is pink blood but it's
wet wet is red and it turns into a
darker color when it dries okay thank
you to the forensic expert
linlin basic facts so why is it paying
this Suite had like 100,000 likes like
10 million views and if you look into
this it's all over the place of
people co-signing this liking it so
what's happening here they're they're
looking at the scene of a of a child who
was butchered by
Hamas and they're saying that it's fake
they're saying not only is it fake but
Israel is lying to us
about people dying like there there is
right before our eyes
on a much much smaller
scale this historical
revisionism you
know uh it's in the same vein as
Holocaust
denialism we know kids died we know lots
of kids
died so what does it first of all what
does it even
matter if it is fake we know the kids
died
that being said it's definitely not
fake I like that these people think that
the Israeli government is at one hand
too dumb to properly uh stage
a a death scene because a little pink
splatter and at the same time they're
too uh smart and
cunning because we own the world or
maybe that's not what they maybe that's
not a fair
uh that's not a fair
characterization but imagine
like that you're having a whole debate
over the scene of where like a beautiful
innocent child died and you all are
sitting there talking on about how it
didn't happen you're sure it didn't
happen it's fake I mean that's I'm sorry
once again that's
just um most of our chat is saying that
it's fake it's it's not fake you guys
I'm sorry to tell you why why would you
say it's fake I mean that's horrible
thing to say I don't know especially so
you this the first time hearing about
any of this so let me ask you this you
think it's fake because there's a little
pink splatter on the
calendar so is that enough so so so this
hunch that you have is enough to go and
and
publicly call this site where a little
girl was murdered a that it never
happened that it was fake I see that
there was a community tweet on that
tweet or Community yeah it's being
brigaded by everybody I saw posts of
people being like get in here and and
upvote this to say it's fake like it's
just it's a total [__] right the
note's not there anymore yeah cuz it got
erased cuz it was [__] it said it
the note was something absurd like oh
yeah blood doesn't turn pink when it
goes on like some dumb [__] this readers
added context they thought people might
want know de oxygenated blood has a
shade of dark red so it is Su staging
the blood is not pink that's really
that's that's a community note that's
like just someone's opinion again I'm
not a [__] scientist and I don't know
why there's little splashes of pink but
I guarantee you in the
complexity in the [__] bodily fluids
being torn and bloodied all over the
place I don't I'm not going to get
caught up in the fact that there's a
little splash of pink on her coloring
book and sit there and
talk and
publicly uh uh say that this little girl
who was killed by terce was
faked you better have a lot more
evidence to say that [__] and again why
are we even discussing this we know the
kids died this is straight
up straight up horrific
propaganda bad it's just
horrible and
again remember the context that I'm
doing this all in in the
beginning you know uh keeping in mind
the the plight of the Palestinians and
the horrible [__] that happens rout
that's happening every minute
there my goal in doing
this is to
maintain a level of
humanity for all
civilians because there's going to be a
blowback from all this [__]
eventually one way or another you know
what I mean and
um I think people are going to have no
problem just killing Israelis and I I
think we saw enough people that are
comfortable with hamama what Hamas did
that I don't think there's I think
there's going to be a lot of people are
just pretty okay with
um with killing Israeli civilians and
I'm and I'm sorry if that makes me you
know somehow insensitive that I don't
think civilians should die on either
side and I don't think it's appropriate
to be guessing on the the murder scene
of a little beautiful innocent girl who
was murdered by a terrorist why she
didn't actually die and why this is
fake like just think about it just think
about what it
means to say this is fake you're saying
to the V majority of people engaging
with this that this did not
happen and saying this did not
happen leads to the Israelis are lying
about everything there this leads to
I've heard people saying the vast
majority of the Hamas Fighters they were
there peacefully it was only a few that
were bad and and and again it's like
this is historic revisionism T it's
comparable to Holocaust I mean obviously
on a way less scale but it comes from
the same place saying like they're lying
they lie about
everything
um I I genuinely don't think this photo
is fake and if you do think it's fake
because of a community note that just
had someone's opinion and I saw
screenshots I saw lots of people being
like everybody getting here and upvote
this this community note just brigading
it it was literally just someone's
opinion
it's not a fact it's not an
article and again I can't get over the
fact like the if the Israeli government
is trying to Stage a death scene why the
[__] would they put
pink on the calendar you think
like how can you you can't think of them
as that
dumb and yet you
know you just can't
it's stupid I don't know am I crazy this
photo is not
fake I I I don't know I mean I I'm only
seeing this for the first time I'm just
seeing that a lot of people think it's
fake uh I I I think it's kind of moot I
mean I think we all agree that innocent
children died that's that's my point too
is that um I think I think it is
important in Wartime to keep a skeptical
mind about things that are coming out
from official sources from both sides so
I can
understand the skepticism but uh I do
agree that the um the full chested uh oh
people saying turn the chat off Dan turn
the chat off okay turn it off we don't
need we don't need people sharing their
opinion on this in chat okay bye-bye bye
everybody the point is is that it did
[__] happen uh yeah I mean um and and
all this all this does is convince more
people that somehow this didn't happen
right somebody uh sent before we just
turned off the chat sent a Super Chat
that um said It reminds them of when
right Wingers claim false flag on uh
school shootings yeah it does have kind
of a similar energy different context
obviously um very different context dude
every single piece of media I've seen
about what happened to um the civilians
who were killed by Hamas is flooded by
comments in the chat of saying it's fake
it looks fake this didn't happen
every time yeah go on Tik Tok go
anywhere you read go into the comment
section I'm just telling you that this
is not this is a dangerous sentiment to
be putting forward this is this is this
is dangerous propaganda that you're
interacting with here what
Dan oh nothing
nothing that's my point on
this it
happened so what's the point of even
being like this is
staged Again full
acknowledgement of the like thousand
plus kids that have died senselessly
murderously
tragically in
Gaza and the horrific conditions they
have I talked about that ow [__] what
was that scratched my
eye yeah I'm okay
I've talked about that at length Okay
because I don't want people to to think
that I'm not caring about that also but
I do think it matters to see propaganda
for what it
is and that all humans all
civilians are deserving of not being
killed this imagine you're wrong though
this is where the scene of where a
little girl her lost her life and then
you're you're just playing guess work
you're playing games about if it's real
for if it's
fake the girl
died that's
real why would they need to F she died
she was murdered by terrorists we I
don't think that's just a fact
right seems a little
silly okay so there's that and then uh
let's see here damn I Clos my dock I'm
almost done here guys for those of you
who are
exhausted with
this
um this was another story I wanted to
share
because there was a moment during our
conversation when I said a lot of the
people who were killed by Hamas were
peace
activists and I knew that because I saw
them
on the TV I saw their families talking
about it I read about them
and Hassan met me with a little bit of
skepticism on
that and I think it's important to again
in an in an act of
humanizing Israeli citizens bring you
this story about uh bilha and yovi were
peace activists and the parents of a
prominent activist moaz Enon they were
killed on Saturday a couple were killed
in their farming Collective which lies
just north of
Gaza so this idea
that you
know aren't the uh the people that live
on Kuts generally they're Communists bro
they're like hippie dippy Comm right
they're literally communist they're it's
[__] a communist organization right
so I guess it's not shouldn't be
surprising that a lot of them I've SE
I've seen a lot of people saying like
anyone that's like uh either they're
talking about the Rave anyone who's
partying outside or living outside of a
concentration camp deserves it I I need
to express first of all how small Israel
is it is not a huge country
so people it's not like there's a huge
amount of diversity of places to live a
lot of Israel is just Barren desert
too so
people are not going there to Revel in
the suffering of
Gins as proof of this article
here that's it and then so
um did you see the
uh that video it was like a 19-year-old
girl who was on one of the Kuts and she
posted a
video
um ranting
about yes how dis she is with the
government and how it's all their fault
and everything yeah that was like pull
it up that video like crushed me but
this is important for people to see
because I I'm just afraid that there's
too many people out there who are
becoming radicalized to think that
Israelis are all genocidal maniacs and I
I feel that it's important for me to and
I keep saying this emphasize here's the
size of Israel just to give you an idea
and by the way like 60% of it is Barren
desert
so I also saw in um Berlin they were
marking the doors of um Jewish people's
homes yeah that's not a good that that's
not a good sign so that's uh yeah that's
what Moses did on uh Passover though
true did he do it he did a oh yeah he
drew swas on their door no no no not
swas that's not what I'm saying he
marked it in blood right yeah send me
that video did you find one with Engish
subtitles uh uh yeah does this have here
this is a girl yeah this is the video I
was talking about so this is an Israeli
girl 4 days after Hamas
attacked this one was a there's a
19yearold girl who survived the horrific
massacre in the Kutz be ay I think that
was the really horrific one where they
were reporting that like b 40 babies got
killed that was the one that really
really really really got [__] yeah
this is her message to fellow Israelis
and to the world again this is the type
type of people that you'll find on these
kabs I know that there's audio listeners
should I I guess maybe I'll I'll read
maybe turn it down and you can just read
along with what she's saying to
translate
yeah all right I'm 19 years old from
kabut
ERI well here I want some audio so I can
hear her inflection in her voice turn up
a little
bit the worst thing aside from hearing
all of the names of the
deceased the missing and unaccounted for
and those taken captive the wor at that
moment was not lying in the dark in a
bomb shelter wasn't hearing the gunfire
wasn't even the real time messages
received from my fellow kots
members people have known since I've
known
myself begging for help and no one
came the worst thing for
me aside from the deceased those held
captive and those who were
abducted was the moment that we exited
our home oh [__] hold on was the moment
that we uh moment that we exited our
home when we were
evacuated it was dark I was barefoot and
I stepped on shattered glass and I saw
the faces of my
neighbors filled with fear absolute
Terror I saw the faces of those who I've
known for as long as I care to remember
in a way that I had never seen them
before in
tears people whom I grew up with filled
with
fear and wondering around here I only
just got here to the Dead Sea oh yeah so
a lot of them got evacuated to like
hotels or vacant hotels up north in the
Dead Sea just for
context wanding around here seeing the
faces of my fellow kabut members
attempting
to get up in the morning to hang in
there to smile once in a
while each in their own
way the hardest thing is to pick myself
up every
morning and it has been a lot of
mornings but each one has been an
extremely difficult challenge just to
pick myself
up what happened to us was
appalling but there's something that is
very important for me to
say what happened to us was nothing new
it was only
worse we've been neglected abandoned for
years for years do not point at the Iron
Dome as a solution do not point at the
soldiers that is a
bandaid someone is dying and you bring
them a Band-Aid shameful
shame we've been talking about this for
years for years they've been neglecting
us that is where this originated from
this was not new only
worse
and this was not and this was not the
only thing that was nothing new only
worse in this
war I'm trying to find the words but
honestly it is quite difficult with all
the anger and grief welling up inside me
right
now how am I supposed to get up in the
morning C of Israel politicians
residents of Israel abroad care who
hears
this listen to me
carefully how am I supposed to get up in
the morning knowing that 4.5 keters from
kabi in Gaza there are people for whom
this event was not this event has not
ended for me it was over 12 hours
because there was a place to be
evacuated to I'm at the Dead
Sea though speaking of Revenge should be
ashamed there's a lot of pain that is
true I myself after everything I've been
through keep losing so much energy every
time I hear the word
revenge for people who go through what I
went through and not have anyone to
extract
them it cannot be I know there can be no
other bandaids they ask us all the time
do you think you'll go back to the kabot
after this to live there without add
protection without additional soldiers
don't offer up soldiers or protection
talk to me about a political solution
years we've been asking for a political
solution I'm 19 years
old I have friends who have fallen on
the battlefield as soldiers over the
past few
days when they were in the kindergarten
they knew what they wanted to do in the
military am I raised my own children
like this shameful
disgraceful might to raise my own
children and ask them when they are 5
years old sweetheart what do you want do
in the
military how much how much lost how much
can one
endure we those of us who survived are
living and walking
proof and believe me if you are hearing
this that
we it can be a whole lot worse it
can in my perspective and this is the
most important thing for me to say right
now
and it's been this way for
years when we are bombarded with rocket
missiles it goes over our heads it's out
of our
control not the rocket missiles they
don't go over our heads the missiles hit
just fine believe
me the decision to launch missiles
that's over my head out of my
control BB Hamas I don't care who is
launching what I do know is that
suffered
suffered CID and to
suffer believe me every missile launched
with only 4.5 km between Gaza and
B causes the ground to shake with the
exact same way in both places the exact
same that is impossible
impossible now I know there's so much
anger towards BB because I feel
it I feel very strongly in the moments
I'm able to feel anything at all because
it's as of late that is not
easy I feel the anger because of how
many people how many Must Die for
him how many people must die for his ego
and his personal
interest I don't know if I already said
this but the missiles particularly in
the latest
attack even before the terrorist
infiltrated I heard more missiles than I
had heard all in my 19 years of Life all
at
once a lot a whole lot and we
immediately knew that this was a war
before the terrorist began everything
we're always the first to know always
the first to hear we can hear it from
where we are the missiles the ones that
hit us feel like missiles launched by my
own
government because this is the
government that has abandoned me my
entire life my entire life and now we
are experiencing the worst of
all and if this isn't the worst of all
only God knows what is in store for
us now it is true that b this and B that
and truly I 100% for
everything that is
true he chose to have us live in this
way he chose to toss us the Iron Dome at
us instead of reaching a political
solution and he shows a lot of other
things as well our blood is on his
hands but it's not just
him he is the root of much deeper
problem but it is not just
him
if my words are heard by anyone take a
good look at yourselves look deep
inside ask yourselves what are your
values ask yourselves in light of
everything you see around you how do
your values the ones you know you hold
fit in with what you
see ask yourselves that question really
ask it ask yourselves who it is you vote
for ask yourself what it is that you are
demanding I know what I am demanding I'm
demanding a peace a just peace
I'm demanding bedin and the ne receive
the same support as Kabir
has and we too did not civilians came to
our rescue civilians the government was
nowhere to be
found and I filled with gratitude for
being at this hotel at the Dead
Sea but in a heartbeat every person here
would give this up to get those held
hostage
back by the way only twice I heard the
government barely even acknowledge the
mere existence of hostages they are
acting as though they don't they do not
exist they drop bombs knowing that these
bombs will cost them their lives
too the return of hostages peace
fairness and
decency if you're not interested in
hearing the things I just said then
there is no
hope take a moment weigh my words
carefully listen
perhaps it's hard for me to speak you
see perhaps for some my words will be
difficult to
hear after what I went through I bet you
owe me this much you owe me
this not in the sense of guilt we are
all dealing with a lot take time just
take a break take care of yourselves
take care of your
families but you owe me
this ask who it is you vote for ask your
what you demanded them and do not
compromise if you hope if you let Hope
die you are letting the you're letting
the residents die over and over again I
have nothing more to
say so this is a very eloquent wow
19-year-old
kabut who is very in touch with her
emotions and obviously a good speaker
but she's far from the only one out
there with that same
opinion
in
fact I'd feel comfortable assuming that
most the people on that Kuts probably
had similar opinions about
stuff and so again when I see people
callously describing Israelis as
celebrating outside a conf concentration
camp they're all settlers to deserve to
be uh murdered by
Hamas I think it's important for
everybody to bear in
mind the cost of Civilian
death and what it
does to on both sides to the psyche of
the people there and how it hurts how
much it hurts peace actual
peace
there was a lot of stuff I saw but a lot
of it was too horrible I couldn't even
read it the
stuff people were saying about me and
Ela I
was I don't
know what good you're getting off of
there let him scream into the
void again just to emphasize
8% of of people in America only 8% are
critical of Israeli
government so I'm not forgetting who's
the aggressor and who is the villain in
this
story but in the words of Gary Vee
different perspectives all it comes back
to Gary doesn't it different perspective
the great thinker of our
time
[__] the Jordan Peterson heads Gary ve
is the philosopher your
Century yeah now put that phone down
different perspectives oh
yeah all
right anything
else I just want to reemphasize that you
can't generalize about anyone obviously
I mean my own experience my grandfather
in Lebanon was a very educated man he
was a wealthy man he was like the head
of the village he trained with British
Knights well respected and he lost his
home to Israel him and my dad's family
and he kind of lost his mind after that
and it completely ruined my dad's family
my grandmother fled to America and my
dad and his siblings and uh they went
through hell after that and it had an
impact that leads all the way to me and
my siblings mhm but then on the other
hand of things I was hired by two
Israelis and you guys completely saved
our lives like you not only gave us
great jobs but allowed us to uh achieve
our dreams and uh yeah I don't know I
just I always thought that was uh a
great example of I can't uh generalize
around
anyone thanks for sharing
that um the one thing I keep saying that
you know I I just one takeaway is that
we are not the crimes of our
government because if we
were then Heaven would be
empty everybody would be
guilty as [__] we' all be child Killers
probably I don't most governments
Western governments and I will say I I
think it's worth saying that I have seen
a lot of total psychopath bloodthirsty
war mongers in the past week saying it's
completely acceptable and good to just
bomb the [__] out of Gaza because they
voted for Hamas right which is psycho
right and that first of all the the the
Hamas analogy is first of all really bad
but even if it was true
mhm let's let's still not kill them all
right theas well and there hasn't been a
vot uh they haven't actually voted on
anything since 2006 I believe and so as
you pointed out that you know over half
the population that are children weren't
even alive during that vote so I don't
see how that they can be culpable for
that but that's besides the point
they're not culpable for that they're
not no and Hamas is their government
listen if you like it or not they're a
terrorist organization they're also
their government that's the people in
charge you know what I mean and
so and I've seen so many I've been
watching a lot of footage
of of what's happening in Gaza there's
reporters there surveying the damage
talking to people I've heard so many of
them saying like we don't support
Hamas 99% of us don't support Hamas we
just want freedom we just want to not be
killed we just want water and food and
[__] like
that yeah but that's I mean
again that's important to bear in mind
because our politicians even more than
the media it's kind of interesting our
politicians are the most bloodthirsty
freaks genocidal Maniacs like they
refuse to have any Nuance they talk
about looking at someone as a
one-dimensional human being I mean that
listen if if you want to talk about a
group of people being looked at as
one-dimensional it's the
um it's the Palestinians mhm by people
who really have power like these
politicians that are
like we to go on a holy war we s oh God
lindsy that [__] went on TV and
said this is a Rel a holy
war I mean same that George Bush said
after uh 911 so we were going on a
crusade there's so much like just
disgusting feelings that I felt after
911 and the leadup to the Iraq War and
everything everything uh being brought
back by all this and it
it's so many people have learned
nothing oh one thing I did want to say I
don't know if I mentioned this but
seeing all the uh Muslims or Arabs or I
I don't know a a group of swath of um
sharing that clip of me talking about um
what's happening at
Palestine and seeing the really
like really the seeing how happy and how
you know how it made them feel just that
very simple expression of
empathy really did make me
realize that a lot of you know Muslims
around the world and
Arabs are just looking for like the
tiniest bit of
empathy yeah because like I didn't give
him that much I'm just one dude who was
really sad
about kids dying and their fathers
having to you know yeah carry their
bodies and and and the seeing how that
touched
people it it puts in perspective just
how little you know a lot of them are
asking
for little s mhm
all right let's take a little break I'll
go to the bathroom and then we'll come
back and do uh our normal show okay
we'll get to the Goof yeah which is all
fun after this all good times um this
might be a good opportunity I know that
this is kind of a a hard switch but
while you go do that um do you want me
to handle this raffle situation go ahead
okay
so the music feels so weird coming off
of that can we
just pal pallet cleanser here
Olivia 543 2 1
[Music]
54321 everybody just needs to watch
Attack on Titan we're just shaking yeah
that that's an acting exercise that's
what ab and I were talking about if we
just got to get them all to sit down and
watch watch Attack on Titan it will
solve everything we'll fix this whole
thing generational violence let's air
drop the DVD I'm going to turn the uh
live chat back on so um okay so uh
during our members drive a couple weeks
ago we did some Raffles um for all of
those old H3 props and everything
unfortunately one of the winners uh
never reached out and uh we gave them a
little bit of time
but
uh haven't heard from them so uh they're
gone so I went ahead and uh drew a new
winner
so Jessica
Ruiz rui who has been a member for 36
almost 37 months
you are now the winner of one of the
raffle prizes so your name is Jessica
Ruiz and uh you've been a member for 36
months since that is probably a fairly
common name and there's probably more
than one of you out there um6 so if your
name is Jessica and you haven't been a
member for 36 months you're not a winner
36 but if your name is Jessica and you
have been a member for 36 months uh
congratulations please reach out to me
or one of the mods and uh we'll get your
info and we will ship you off um a neat
little Prize
Package so
congratulations and and L to the person
who didn't uh ever reply you better hope
nothing happened to them they I hope
they're okay yeah that's a good point I
hope you're okay I hope you're okay
maybe they just they were like I don't I
I don't really
loser we do hope you're good we hope
you're good loser get a subreddit post
hi this is the significant other of the
first he was not okay he was not
okay uh all right uh do one more
surprise raffle for the people uh well
this was it I mean we just did you're
saying do another another one I don't
have another prize lined up I'm sorry
but um maybe sometime in the near future
here we'll uh we'll keep going
with some more
prizes so anyways uh what's up everybody
I guess we already did the how is your
weekend thing let's get let's let's get
in the weeds a little bit more what do
we actually do this weekend what are you
up
to let's hear it don't hold back what
you do I oh my God I hung out with
friends I let me look at my camera roll
to remember okay I played the uh because
I was sick I did basically nothing but
played uh computer games how you feeling
now fun huh you feeling better I I feel
way better today today today I have
conquered the cold
nice Lena went to the uh screening the
Taylor Swift uh yeah she went Taylor
lner was hosting it with his wife and
Lena met them yeah that's pretty cool uh
Ian really wanted to send me to the
premiere night of the Taylor Swift thing
to do a thing for the show um um but
that was the first day that I was
feeling really sick and I was like I I
cannot do that right now R cause a super
spreader event with all the swifties
they would never forgive me I went to a
Premiere last night it wasn't the Taylor
Swift one but it was the Rick and Morty
season premiere Party Rick and
mor inv me see Justin was Justin there
for some reason Justin didn't show up I
don't know what happened was there he
sounded different on the show too I
don't know what happened there are you
friends with somebody who works on the
show or something is that why you
invited I'm friends with yes some
producers and stuff that are still
around there but you know thanks for
inviting me shout out shout out it was a
weird time yeah it's
very attenion was in the air oh um
Ethan's back oh one one thing I want to
clarify I guess is
that wait are you going back to the
Israel thing cuz we did like no kind of
not really we did a big like shake off
the bad vibes thing we did yeah yeah I
mean we can go back I want to say I just
want to say this cuz I don't want it to
seem like I said that girl was Hassan's
mod and I just want to make it clear
that I'm not Hassan has been a great
friend he's been very caring I've been
talking to him the whole time about all
this he's been Express he he is a
genuine and a great friend and somebody
who does not support a lot of the stuff
that people have been saying and I just
want to make it clear that he has been a
good sweet true friend to me and we've
been talking this whole time and he's
been very supportive and very
nice what's on I don't want anyone to to
think
otherwise let make true this fruit he
did a big fundraiser didn't he yesterday
yeah he raised what like half a million
or something it's over that now yet in
the 700 that's oh my [__] god really
trying to see where they how they Jesus
I have to say I did uh I threw a couple
hundred bucks in there on that one damn
Dan okay we love a couple hundred bucks
on there we love Dan I donated uh that's
but when I did it it was around like
150,000 or something how is they get the
aid in like what's the means of getting
that money to the people uh well I
believe the organization that he's
working with is a pretty reputable one
and uh just curious about logistics
because I know it's a [__] show that
well frankly yeah it's probably a
problem um I like we talked about
earlier I believe Aid is now being
allowed in through the Egyptian border
somewhat uh so presumably that way cuz I
don't think it's any other way it's kind
of that like up until a few days ago
nobody could even help
them people were donating money to these
uh right and like where that even going
or humanitarian they're like no you you
can't even come in here
right yeah yeah yeah
yeah uh let me um I'm trying to find
where
[__] with the ads bro he's 6,500
6,500 away from 800k wo so okay okay
okay crazy where's
Lena I think she's uh with Ela today
right yeah Ela if you're listening let's
donate
65,000 and get it to oh push it over the
top let's get it oh [__] can you uh are
you reaching out to Lena yeah
okay let's [__] go right now dude
thatd be pretty
epic but yeah he's been slamming all day
on that so shout
out that's crazy I mean at that rate
it's going to hit a million which is
nuts yeah I think it
will [__] that's a lot of it's a lot of
food and Medicine yeah
hopefully like you said hopefully it
gets there to the people that need it
the crazy thing to remember about
Gaza I don't think many people can
understand how weird this is they cannot
leave they can't go anywhere
they're stuck they're stuck they can't
leave like even refugees have certain
rights to like you know exit Harm's Way
and go find safety somewhere else they
can't they can't leave dude right they
can't even try
to um is they're totally blocked off by
Israel mostly and
Egypt they can't [__] go anywhere
yeah I don't think there's anywhere else
in the world where
like they're caged in they literally
can't
leave they're caged in by like
sophisticated
military technology
yeah that's by the way they built it
like so you can't even dig tunnels or
anything because that's how the
terrorists used to do
attacks they would build deep ass
[__] columns into the Earth so you
can't even tunnel out damn damn yeah you
cannot leave you're stuck there it's
crazy yeah yeah not good
times not
good all
right um okay
unrelated but one of our mods just let
me know because while you were gone we
were talking about the uh oh it's only
seven oh wait how much did you say it
was oh I see yeah yeah yeah while you're
gone we were talking about uh the raffle
and people were like do another prize I
was like oh I don't have any other uh of
the prizes lined up or whatever well one
of our mods just offered up for a future
one if we ever do this
again he's got four of the [__]
butthole dude pour the goods how' you
wind up with four dude dude you need to
spread the love brother that's
capitalism that is everything wrong with
capitalism he said I tried to give it to
my family as a gag gift and they all
accepted it and dropped it on me when I
was about to drive home for the h
so they rejected your gift well my
friend so not cool man buto you're
sitting on a pile of gold my friend
literal so next uh next time we want to
do a giveaway maybe we'll uh we'll throw
one of these rare butthole candle we
should reissue can we reach back out to
the candle folks I think it's time to
reissue you want to do another round
candle you know I never got to smell it
what fantastic I never got to smell it
wait how I don't know I never got to
smell it but didn't we oh wait were oh
we were still in the basement when we
were doing this I believe so we weren't
in the studio for people that weren't
watching back then it was gwenneth
paltro was doing that it smells like my
vagina candle yeah and so we went into
the you know the
laboratory we went to experts and we
made it smells like my butthole candle
that smells like farts when yeah it was
a it was a company that specialized in
odd sents they I think from what I
remember they made weird smells for like
uh Theme Park attractions and stuff you
know when you go into a place and so
like they they literally specialized in
like capturing very specific weird
smells so interesting yeah so they did
pretty good it smelled real bad can we
reach can do you still in contact with
them I mean sure I mean I I I have a
whole long email chain with them from
it's a shame we only made like 3 of them
I I wasn't sure if people were going to
buy them or not it was a little
expensive cuz you know it's a nice
candle right I think we can move a lot
of butthole candles this
year it's probably too late for the
holidays unfortunately just because it's
already late like mid day comes up early
oh Valentine's Day a romantic that's not
a bad idea female vaginas are disgusting
that is not a bad idea what was that my
female vaginas are disgusting uh didn't
ask but that is interesting to know
about you disagree but okay all
[Applause]
right
all right so let's see guys I have a new
Tik Tok
Obsession um I love this [__] I I watch
it's like my whole feed at this point
and again this is why I love Tik Tok
nowhere else in the world would I be
introduced to this kinds of stuff so
this is I think it's in Thailand I'm not
100% sure maybe it's Vietnam Vietnam
what what what language is
this uh that looks like
Vietnamese to me might be Vietnamese
right but I am far from an expert so I
don't want to say the wrong thing
apologize if I'm wrong assess Google
that is Vietnamese Vietnamese
[Music]
okay
did I get
that maybe wow I can't believe he didn't
think of that you can't believe I didn't
think about it or I think about the
bottom I didn't get it no oh
great it was a note about some of my
heated I'll just explain it cuz I don't
want people's imagin I don't know how
that happened why was that copy
your computer that was so weird I cop i
l it's not even close to where I'm
typing I copied this Twitter link or Tik
Tok link I don't know I think you may
have potentially dictated it because Mac
has a feature where if you dictate
something it could come up if it was
said he's not on Mac though well oh no I
just broke the illusion oh no it's still
the the dude it's not even close it's
not even close to where I typed at I
don't got a clue man you have you have a
special bro that makes no sense you have
a special skill when it comes to
computers I got to tell you so anyway I
was just a note about wanting
to a heated exchange I had on Twitter I
just wanted to unpack it a little more
MH that's it I I don't really want to
talk about it though wait they didn't
hear it huh they did miss it they didn't
see it you got it whatever doesn't
matter be you're wrong just just stop it
does move on it
yeah I apologize to him and I wish him
all the
best and yes he does have a very nice
mustache somebody asked me to say and
I'll I'll I'll give him
that uh okay here it
is so the
Vietnamese uh Jade
miners I'm going to need your guys'
input here this is one of the rare ones
where he actually
gets the
Jade the vast majority of him are losing
so he I got to mute it cuz it has
music it didn't get climed yo that's
awesome cuz the music is so [__] good
the music's so good wait wait let me let
me just the last time I check let me let
me just let me just make sure 100%
because I do not want to oh my goodness
that that's such good news for me also
real quick Lena messaged you in Discord
yeah oh yeah
uh should I make make the donation
yes to get it to 1
million not to a million or I mean wait
wait wasn't it 800,000 that it was on I
mean 800 no no don't do
it wait wait wait wait wait oh
no just throw 200k in there wow I mean
this guy is very generous you know why
okay I love the help yeah right yeah
yeah let's just start with start 7,000
whatever it is um yeah there's no claim
on it either okay great oh my God you
guys I'm so excited to share this
here so this this one's unusual but so I
was confused though um because they held
out that currency yeah yeah and that
didn't look like Vietnamese
money so now I'm not
sure maybe the captions are just in
Vietnamese uh are you sure it's not
Vietnamese money I looks like Chinese
money yeah that's our boy Ma isn't it I
thought so and I just looked up what
Vietnamese currency looks like and it
doesn't look like wait look at the money
that's ma that's our boy right there
yeah so here the
legend you on let's see what it looks
like oh yeah that's definitely Chinese
money so when then oh that's interesting
Okay so so maybe it's just well maybe
it's just reposted on a Vietnamese page
so I just have Vietnamese cap godamn it
I guess it's probably not even worth
debating because it doesn't really
impact the video does it well no it is
it's something that I've honestly
wondered a lot about oh okay like where
this is taking place there's one
specific Channel I'm looking for that I
God damn it I put the
wrong
um the wrong page in my
document but okay let me just play this
one
sorry this is like the biggest up ever
for the sake of Tik
Tok right so so they buy a rock and then
the guy slaps it with the
money then he goes cuts it open okay and
I guess they're looking for Jade they
have this light I don't know what
they're looking
for so he and then and then every time
they lose they just like throw the
rock um oh so it's like wait it's like
gambling it is it is gambling who this
is like something that would be in like
a Zelda game it it's it is gambling it's
gambling but then other times they use
the Jade to make stuff it's so
interesting I don't understand it I mean
I know I understand it it's really cool
actually just so bizarre and so
interesting and they just the rocks
are it's good it's real good so was that
good cuz I can't tell you can see some
illumin you see the light the rock okay
wait let me go back let me go back no
you see no cuz I no see he threw that
one you're wrong that one was worthless
the [__] it's [__] get it out of here
yeah why did he make a happy face cuz
these guys are all super ironic they're
just like they're all like so
blackpilled about gambling yeah like
it's really funny that was Chinese too
wait that money looked different yo
that's good
yo so now right okay so now they build
something so he's cutting it out he's
giving it to the
guy the guy he it's like a lottery
ticket with jade stones I mean what the
heck it's like the game in Webkins when
you would go to the coals and you would
click and you would only get three
clicks and if you found a gemstone you
got points but if you didn't that was it
for the day right so the little video
game sounds when they uh get this isn't
my favorite one though where's my
favorite Guy come on he's the only one
that matters let me check my Tik Tok I
follow him this is important you'll be a
you'll be able to pick it up this is
going to be A's new limited manga shop
that's him this guy chat said this is in
genin you're right Dan so there you go
there's actually a video game that has
rock gambling in it oh it isn't a game
that's according to this chatter oh wait
did he Alli just started playing that
genin game so uh I I'll have to ask her
so here is um so this this is the one I
love this is my guy okay limited manga
shop so they he always buys it from this
dude it's wrapped plastic he slaps it
with the money I guess for good luck I'm
assuming mhm crushes it he's so black
filed he hates that he does
this cuts it
open I I go I think that rock looks
pretty that's a pretty Rock but then
it's not throws it I think it looked
pretty because sometimes it's w and all
of those bags are just full of these
rocks yeah wow and then like how do they
know how do they regulate this like how
do they know how much rocks have Jade
where do they get these rocks right yeah
that's a good question so cuts it open
you know he's right I guess the the
people the Proprietors wouldn't know
either cuz you don't know until you I
know what's in a rock right so they
couldn't like well you can pick which
one you want too and I go that's a
pretty that's a beautiful looking Rock
nope it's trash [__] garbage that's
devastating it's
trash one man trash I'll go grab that
out of the bin I don't know why but I
will I like to be a part of this world
it seems you want to get into Southeast
Asian Jade d i game I love the
camaraderie between the guys you seem to
be having a good time okay so that that
one's a winner and I don't get it wait
wait wait okay we got to look carefully
at what the light looks like so this
one this one has Jade in it are you sure
it's Jade uh I think it's Jade it says #
Jade okay I think it's I about it right
true I thought it was a
so okay that sure looks like all wait no
no no it's definitely glowing more
around the edges the other one's kind of
glowed like that there's always like a
little bit of glow because the light's
so close to it but that one to me looked
like it was cam do me a favor radiating
out a lot more grab a still of this one
under the light and then the one of the
losers under the light can you link me
that
video uh yeah link that video
yeah we're going to get to the bottom of
this but I you guys will see I just love
the camaraderie also the guy has really
great sense of humor how he trashes the
Rocks every time I'm just really inv I
just really involved in this guy's
life so he's cutting out a jade Pearl
wow and he made a he made a he's made a
pretty a bracelet bracelet does he sell
the bracelet does he just want want a
jade
bracelet who knows who's to say I don't
know um but I love I love being here
with him let's see this dude's only got
a
basket he's trying and then he's trying
to goof the guy look he's try he's like
no slaps his hand take this one cuz I
guess he doesn't have enough money this
a different song so I'm just going to
turn it you see this it's so fun and why
is there tape around some
rocks good question well they're more
professional
outfit well so this is a big rock we're
going to cut it open and see what's
inside and then another thing I've
wondered is does this guy have a stone
cutter or does he use a stone cutter at
the gambling facility oh right yeah
probably that because like jeez it seems
having a whole stoneworking shop is so
that that looks pretty right but he
caught it
badly it based off of what I'm seeing I
think he's going to say this one's a
winner me
too oh yeah see it's the it's the
radiate it's got to like radiate out
from the light so some of them just turn
it in for money but some of them
actually use it mhm in stone
making so what how much is imagine
you're a jewelry jewelry maker but this
is how you uh Source your inventory that
this is how do it it's so weird here
check check this place out 700,000 Yen
That's like [__] how much is that
that's
$5,000 wait Yen wait yen is a Japanese
currency 700k it's Chinese currency we
we decided well this one looks different
too I think this is probably look like
Vietnamese cuz it's got the elephant on
it
mhm it's possible that
like like how American currency is uh F
was that like how American currency can
can get you by in a lot of places um
Chinese currency might be acceptable in
bordering you know what I mean true so
here the right one is the
winner so the left so if it's green it's
not a winner no you see how it has like
a much more like organic like the light
is is on the right is radiating from
within yeah it's like being absorbed by
the stone exactly on the left it's just
reflecting off the surface I think
that's how you can tell all right let's
see if we can spot winner
then so here look at this Stone
Factory and then they give him like
little bonus stuff I don't know what it
is he gave him like a calendar or
[Music]
something sckers so we're cutting open
the stone he's he's he doesn't like
doing this I mean he's you know he's
black fi he throws it at is this the
narrative you've created in your head
it's true look how he throws it that's a
loser right that's a loser for sure yeah
you see how it doesn't Bloom yeah
[__] so there you go byebye in the
TR he tosses that [__] he really threw
that one how much did he buy this one
for it's how much is 700,000 in
Vietnamese that's 100,000 oh Vietnamese
yeah Vietnamese bot I think it's called
I just got to the shinese
Yan okay it's going to be uh wildly
different exchange
rates let's take a look I and I root for
him I want him to win so
bad so is that one that's a loser yeah
yeah it's right in
he's back he's getting black pilled he
he is look he doesn't you know he's like
here we go again I'm just trying to make
some jewelry literally he just keeps
getting knocked down he's like
sopus here we go with the stone yes
absolutely good reference believe in
this
oneus byebye must imag this guy happy
damn so this the majority of them are
just him losing I would say 90% or more
are him just losing every time and just
being upset but once in a while he
wins and I I wish I could find the one
where he does these really intricate
Jade he does like a laser engraving on
some of them it's like really
interesting little
statuettes so here we go we got a little
carrying bag I don't know what these are
just a little Stone thing
Dollop by the way Ethan um I don't know
why we're uh promoting gambling to our
young audience this is kind of [__] up
guys please only buy Jade rocks
responsibly buy Jade rocks responsibly
please xqc is looking for a new sponsor
he's reaching out okay unironically if
xcc did this it would be better than
what he does with the slots that would
be [__] awesome yeah yeah I got
it so that one's a loser right it's got
uh yeah yeah clearly here we go we're
going does he ever win he does rarely
rarely and I I don't know what those are
he gives them something to compare it to
just a
little I don't know it's just a little
treasure I think a little treasure
so that's a big that's a loser yeah he
goes bye not even worthy of the TR the
trash can
yeah yeah I love this [__] man he he
swoops it from him he won't give him the
treasure this time see look at you had
enough you're cut off yeah and I don't
know he wants one but the dude says nah
bro this guy does you have a
problem this is awesome so we're cutting
open the
rock we son I'm genuinely hypnotized by
this now yeah I love it this I
think see so again they're all losses
wow that whole video he didn't win once
and what's interesting these 30 million
views yeah yeah well the top most viewed
ones are him losing when he actually
wins they don't get a lot of views isn't
that weird people like just laughing at
him his Misfortune here's one that has
400,000 which is a lot less than the
other ones let's see how many views this
one
got let's give that a good slap for good
luck here we're going to cut this one
open I'm only hoping this one's a winner
cuz it doesn't have a lot of
views all right let's take a listen
guys H that might be nope fat L's oh
yeah I thought so too also I love his SL
are those like fake Yeezys in those no
no no how dare you I don't know what are
you saying no like they don't they're
I'm not saying he has fakes no sorry are
those Yeezys those are not Yeezys no
okay yeah sorry I didn't mean to put
they did kind of look like it I I didn't
mean to assume we're about to Yeezy bust
the Jade Gambler the Jade
Guy what's that a pack of cigarettes
let's go bonus you know going to the
corner store to get a Jade stone and
cigarettes look at that that thing's
Green Oh I feel good about this one it's
green how could it not be a jade come
on oh that thing trash trash loser
idiot I've seen one on where he goes to
like big ass Ravines and toss thems in
there and he got a pomelo I mean okay
that's a nice
bonus table I like
Theos so let's see it's like a
multiplier when you buy
multier he got two stones what for one
yeah he got a multiplier all right let's
take a look guys not feeling
good oh that thing looks rough hold on
that's 500 buy do you see though it's
it's oh he didn't throw it maybe he's
going to throw them all together yeah
he's going to throw them all together
okay what do we think no no l [__]
idiot terrible dog let's see let's see
how he discards them
and the just the pamelo yeah interesting
so did he keep the
stones he's got a problem
dude look how much money this one is
he's a stoner oh this guy's my favorite
uh seller he's super
funny you're really deep with this huh
you have you have a favorite really
funny Jade Merchant no this guy he's
always in a really good mood he's all
smiles and he's funny you know I often
feel pretty negative about the
internet's influence on Humanity but the
fact that a man in Southern California
can be so invested in Southeast Asian
gambling is uh that's a beautiful thing
they're so it's like I just love these
guys they seem have such a good attitud
honestly I think you'd get along with
them you think so I'd love to do the
Jade cutting with them just's cut some
Stones together all right let's see
let's stack it you know he cares about
him you could tell all
right all right this is the last one
guys I won't make you watch this anymore
okay just hoping for I could watch this
the whole rest of the episode I could
too I already do at
home see that looks like an El but you
see into the [__] River That's my boy
oh you're right oh you're right I love
him too I'm so dude he I love his energy
dude he went back to find him a special
stone let me go back like he he he's
rooting for
us it's us oh yeah look good scrambling
over those rocks yeah dude get after
it all right ooh that's a big boy oh he
cut the C The Cutting spot
interesting it looks kind of sketch too
I'm scared of those machines see now
dude yes yes yes yes yes yes good no why
no no no no he he's
trolling he was
[Applause]
trolling gorgeous we know our Jade we
know J dude look that is a beautiful
Jade bracelet that really is stunning
might even call so how much would it
like a a a jade bracelet like that sell
for kind of look like a shower curtain
ring if I'm being honest
solid okay all right well Hey listen why
am I the ha you're over here hating on
jade look solid Jade bracelet yeah yeah
yeah how
much uh it looks like you could buy one
of those
[Music]
the prices are wildly varying so I don't
know what to believe here dealing with
the the best highest grade [__] well uh
on this website uh which is uh
gumps gumps San Francisco is selling a
oh God that's a
that get out of
here this is
$7,000 but I'm seeing lots of them that
are like a couple hundred bucks so I
don't know what's special about this a
couple hundred dude pure Stone bracelet
Jade that's why I way surprised by the
variation I was seeing I'm seeing ones
on Etsy for 45,000 50,000 what yeah dude
pure Dre chunk like that is is Macy's
$144 I whenever I watch is this like
just fake fake F yeah it's fake click it
let's see it'll probably say like uh
pseudo fa Jade or something Jade yeah
yeah you have to imagine it being Jade
fox
show whenever I watch the Antique Road
Show or some my favorite moments from
that show is when they recover like
these super massive intricate jade
statues and I think finding a big
continuous chunk of Jade is is very
valuable I mean I don't know how
reputable this is this site has a bunch
for $500 is so I don't know I guess
maybe it just depends on the the
Purity well he only deals with the most
pure but this is interesting I'll tell
you this um gambling on Stones is the
practice of buying a Raw Stone and then
cutting it open with the hopes of
holding gems inside if a jade is in the
stone the buyer can make a huge profit
but if the stone holds nothing the buyer
has bought a valueless rock at a high
price an increasing number of people
have been seeking jadeite Dreams by
gambling on stones and the
union excuse me the un Province for in
recent years the Jade industry has
created more than half a million
jobs un according to the latest data
from the Jim and J Jewelry quality
Supervision in dude Inspection Office
holy [__] that's the longest government
name ever Jem and J Jewelry quality
supervision inspection
office so apparently uh there are
actually and this would explain the wild
variation in the prices there are
several types of Stones known in English
as Jade um so no I'm sure they all look
similar but there's there's some Jade
are rarer than others I guess this is
real jade no I believe it but that just
explains why some is like super
expensive and some is pretty affordable
this man is harvesting real serious Jade
here's one that looked like maybe he
sets sells it on Etsy you know here it
is
50,000
that's 50 that's a fat chunk can I see
it on and see it
says it's kind of braid a jadeite that's
a flex walk around the store a little yo
[__] xqc hook up my jade yeah
bracelet whole house on his wrist how
strong is Jade will that break if I for
sure bang
it you think it would just break it's
probably pretty strong I think it's
fairly hard Stone let's see how strong
is Jade because I mean they're sawing it
really not delicately Jade is very tough
the toughest known natural mineral three
times tougher than Ceramics and even
tougher than
steel this explains why it was used in
Neolithic times for knife blades and ax
heads and later for ornamental carvings
yo how is that possible it's Jade
brother well it's because the like
hardness is different like there's
differentes of
uh right like something could be really
uh
really hard but brittle you know can
snap easily essentially so and then I
had depends not Jade this interlocking
structure gives Jades its toughness and
outstanding workable properties even
under extreme stress it doesn't break or
deform easily Jade Jade Jade Jade Jade
Jade Jade Jade Jade Jade Jade J in 2020
it generated $4 billion yo I need to get
we got to get in the Jade industry bro I
I all of a sudden have a dream it's 14 I
have a pipe dream too pick up my entire
life and move
to move to uh soueast Asia what was it
called the The
Province
you so excuse me un unon dude where is
that youan
Province let's see your home this is my
future home this is is in the beautiful
country of it's like it's near the
border of China Vietnam oh yeah so there
you go that explains yeah it does border
Vietnam so my dream uh is to
relocate to unin and become a prolific
Jade Trader Jade Merchant M you know
there it's such a nice it seems like a
nice Carefree life is like you
know it's fun everyone's not taking it
too seriously and just having a really
really good time out there shout out
Union
Province all right so that's my new Tik
Tok obession
everybody good news to bed
makers I saw this post bed makers Yep
this post cracked me up I saw
it making your bed makes you 206% more
likely to become a millionaire let's go
let's get it boys wow I'm going to go to
bed and I'm going to be happy I'm about
to be rich as [__] [__] you're you're
prolific bed maker oh yeah yeah mhm I am
not for the rest me neither and you're
going to go to bed and you're still
going to be a [__] loser I
think true okay ninja chill dude I just
think these alpha alpha isms are so
[__] goddamn stupid like make your
bed and you're just going to magically
become a millionaire I believe
that according to CBS News CBS News this
is the research you guys are doing study
the habits of the Rich and found that if
you make your bed each
morning yeah but that's not it has to be
the habits of the
rich correlation rich people for the
most part very rich people they
definitely ain't making their own beds
that's a good point too right they have
people for that and second of
all uh what I'd like to know their
Source on this I'd like to know the
research parameters Randall some what
did it say are you a millionaire do you
make your bed I what the [__] kind of
questionnaire is that Jesus
isce it's crazy well it also it impli it
imply here's the thing is like maybe you
could find some correlation between like
the personality type that is very uh
yeah uh rigid and uh and hardworking or
whatever and they tend to make their bed
but like putting that out there is like
suggesting to people so if you want to
get rich start making your bed and it's
like no it doesn't doesn't go that
direction according to us according to
research people that go to the bank more
often have a higher chance of being
wealthy right I got to go to the bank
more according to research I am well on
my way let's go let's go I'll make my
bed just to sit on top of it this sounds
like a big bed propaganda right I agree
actually bed top comment is it says it's
false guys my mom paid for this ad so
she could get me to make my bed every
day right um I have an even spicier take
that I uh I tested out here I was like I
have something that I think is going to
be pretty controversial I tested it out
here with the crew and immediately
everybody was yelling at me as soon as I
even brought it up so let me uh let me
find this real quick I'm very curious
um what your take is on this I'm dream
when you're me uh apparently here was
Washington Post article are you ready
for this go
ahead experts say don't pre-rinse your
dishes who pre- rinses their dishes what
does that mean like when you're putting
loading up the dishwasher oh yeah that's
psycho you have to you have to rinse you
have to okay well universally that is
rejected by quote unquote experts which
I am very curious who is an like what do
we mean by experts here I've tried it
does not come out clean man I agree
experts almost uniformly agree that
dishes do not need to be rinsed and in
fact should not be rinsed before going
in the dishwasher saying it waste water
and might make your machine operate less
efficient it is true when you're rinsing
dishes you're going 80% the way of
cleaning it and then you're using more
water that part I can understand the
water wasting part but they are they are
saying you're straight up doing yourself
a disservice should not be rinsed kind
of horeshit is this no that's so stupid
I'm sorry that's so dumb because your
dishwasher is going to get all clogged
up and then if it if there's any form of
like smell it's going to
be right good what happened AB we just
out of reaction Ian switched to Sam
because she started talking but her
camera is over here so uh that's yeah
Sam is just a black screen right Sam
well we'll plug it in listen there's
nothing more that we all want to be true
look everyone is screaming in the chat
right now that this is psychopath do a
poll [__] do a poll wait let's let's
nothing more than I want to be true is
that you don't have to pre-rinse what
should I pull should i p do you do this
or or do you agree that you shouldn't
like what what is the nightmare do do
you no no do you m do you need to
pre-rinse dishes for dishw put in
diswasher there there's nothing that we
want more as a society than to not
pre-wash the dishes this is the Utopia
we were promised yeah just begging for a
second cycle we should ask Tom Ward
doesn't he work with that before he
became a podcaster he does dishwash
stuff I think so like a dishwasher
dishwasher salesman dishwasher salesman
that's what I've
heard D you heard that is that real or
are you joking misunderstood it cuz he
said he works with appliance sales and I
thought that was dishwashers he did say
he came from sales there's okay so
you're on to something maybe I think we
should ask we should figure it out have
Tom settled this uh one in five people
in our audience say that you shouldn't
that you do not need to pre-rinse your
dishes so there's actually more support
for this than I expected do not it's
pretty low do not that's one and five I
I'm saying I'm saying in this office
there wasn't a single person that didn't
scream at me when I said this I'm just
saying when we do these polls 80% is
like a [__] blowout I mean you could
you could do the PLL are you breathing
and then there'd be 20% that say should
we test that just to
just to see well it' be it won't be a
serious B you know all right so moving
on thank you to the dishwashing folks of
America and the world
frankly uh it is a much bigger
place I heard a lot of people had the
Dream It's a nightmare stuck in their
head over the nightmare I can't sleep a
nightmare you're not there Jesus Christ
nightmare a nightmare you're not there
you're not there red says my sister and
I watch every episode of the show and
it's brought us closer to over the years
thank you Ethan and the crew for
everything you do and Shout Out Maddie
love you bestie love you love you
besties sorry I don't know why it said
red there uh their name is Morgan R so
shout out Morgan R thank you for the
Super Chat thank you guys I I appreciate
that it makes me feel very very nice
love you guys I love you guys even
though you're not
there so here's a post on the subreddit
said
uh yesterday
oh yesterday was one of the worst days
of my life I took the day off work
because I've been uh working with a
doctor for the last few months to get a
diagnosis report so I can get properly
medicated the report was finally done I
spent all morning going over
it with them and they told me I have
autism and
TSD I already knew this about myself but
to have a 16-page report sitting in
front of
you over how severe it was it was a lot
but when I got done I went home to find
my boyfriend waiting for me and when I
walked in the door he told me that he's
leaving me which was a complete
Blindside we talked for hours and made a
plan on what to do next I had a panic
attack and do you know what [__]
stupid [__] was stuck in my head the
whole goddamn time from the time I
opened my eyes to when I was crying
myself myself to sleep all I could hear
was dream singing I can't breathe when
you're not bre when you're not there my
brain is poison [__] dream a
nightmare uh she said she continue I've
been reading your comments All Day
they've been so kind thank you so much I
feel very deregulated at the moment but
I'm trying to stay positive also I love
seeing how many people hate what dream
has done to them let's go well our heart
is certainly with you and
uh I can't breathe when you're not there
I can't sleep it's nightm a nightmare
nightm a nightmare nightmare I
can't you're not there you're not there
I'm so sorry um I wish I could button
that song out of your brain My head goes
numb and my heart beats fast when its
feels like
not there nightmare nightm
nightmare
SLE all right Zach you're torturing the
poor people this girl she she's pouring
her heart and soul out and here you are
nightmare you're just adding another
verse to her nightmare this is a
nightmare anyway we love you and uh I'm
sorry for your dumbass boyfriend loser
[__] and about the PSD I'll only say
this to you you Zach remember and you
know what you do you know what I'm
looking for Zach nightmare no nightmare
no I'm looking for a Robert a Robin
Williams line
perhaps it's not your fault that's the
one it's not your fault I just wanted to
tell you your fault it reminds me of
this wonderful scene from Goodwill
Hunting your fault he brings out this
huge folder of all the diagnosis that
this guy has from his really [__] up
childhood and he goes I just want you to
know well all this here your fault it's
not your fault and that's how I feel
it's not your fault it's not your fault
not your fault all right stop fault your
fault not your fault
stop that's it thank you all
right uh
oh uh dude James Charles no sister
apparel is going under man this is so
sad sisters Hello
Olivia I'm so so sad you guys
sister oh no oh here it
is
um well it's official sister's apparel
is shutting down this video is very
Bittersweet for me to make but it's been
a long time coming so let's talk about
it I started sister apparel back in 2017
I mean I don't know why he's got to
throw in the towel there's Tony of
plenty of good great designs on our
website you can you know yeah
make I was first starting to come up on
social media look at this really
incredible sister
merch it's a hoodie that
says God damn it coming so let's talk
about it I started sisters apparel back
in 2017 I'm
shook first starting to come up on
social media it was right after I
started saying hi sisters in my videos
and I really wanted to get on to the
merch train every YouTuber had it so I
designed some super didn't we also
determine that this is like a font
ripoff of it looks like Yeezy I believe
Yeezy Ian really you're the expert today
brother I don't know about this one but
it looks like the uh Yeezy merch a
little bit Yeezy font I remember there
was one
that repeating yeah here I'll I'll send
it yezy Pablo I know I'm not supposed to
say that Biden
I can't breathe when you're not there
you're not there I I believe that is Old
English font I called can't breathe when
you're out there
nightmare nightmare oh the Pablo oh yeah
because it's not just the the font cuz
clearly it's an Old English font and
that's fine it's the repeating the
repeating element I think
that go num in my heart
all right all right all
right Z stop torturing our our fans man
these people matter uhuh hey um quick
aside uh I just went and used the
restroom real quick and I could don't
yeah I saw that as well don't don't
don't P by the way I wondered before it
started if that was going to happen
you're not there go ahead Dan you're not
there you could say it well
I go ahead spit it up Dan well I think
what he was trying go ahead AB well I
just think it's really funny
that what's funny well earlier when I
went to
the why is why you all got cat got your
tongue I mean what's the problem spit it
out put your balls in my mouth
what all right well uh I guess Dan has
nothing say let's continue watching
sorry for
interrupting yes I clogged the toilet
again I think I I think I okay here's
what I do when I whenever I and I don't
know why like I've been trying to poop
all weekend I've been a little
constipated and the minute I come to the
[__]
office interesting it's so annoying
nightm and then here's another thing
night here's what I nightmare I'm sure
everyone can really I hate when the
toilet water splash up on me for sure so
what I take is I take a paper towel and
I lay I lay it clean and flat over the
water so that when I [__] it doesn't
Splash ever okay did you just misspeak
or are you putting paper towels in the
toilet that so yeah no I didn't misspeak
it's a paper towel okay that's why it's
getting claw we have solved the game we
have exercised the
demons you [__] outside now you got [__]
the
down the toilet you're put whole R papw
in there honestly like flushing tampons
might even be better like I don't I
don't know what do you want me to do my
you're AAL you're the
one
you
unfair why how why does this affect you
guys so much czy because it sits there
stewing and we all know I clean it stew
bro this is worse than a [__] fat
I clean it yeah I know you do but the
thought it's just the fact that we know
it's there and it always happens right
before the show so I don't have time to
deal with it so it's marinated no but
but I put caution cones
outside you didn't go in right no I you
have a whole [__] police barrier set
up yeah it was like a checkpoint but so
here's what I think is happening is I
put a p it's a paper towel flat over the
water and I think what happens is it
just dry like uh here here's what it
suck seals a vacuum seals my [__] yeah
it like bags your [__] and the toilet as
well and it sucks it down perfectly
here's the uh here's the bathroom right
now is that the photo from today or is
that the photo from last week oh is this
from last week or is this today they
they look very similar mean same yeah
yeah that's what it I took one today too
if you want there's a standard procedure
what see the most is that you've been so
like adamant saying that you did you're
not doing anything wrong well I but you
all were acting like I'm do I like I
have giant monster shits or something
like I just walk you didn't have another
explanation because we didn't know until
now that you're shoving paper towels
down there we don't know what the [__]
is going on in there we just know
something's not right right I mean it's
just a paper towel it dissolves in water
it you know what you know what actually
someone on Reddit will pull the clip I
asked last time I said unless you're
flushing something else down there and
you're like oh AB what am I going to be
flushing a toy down there I'm like I
don't know paper towel and it was quiet
it was quiet I don't I mean listen I
think the way I'm using it is probably
not helping but that being said I don't
I think a paper towel will dissolve in
water it's not like a wet
WIP but that being said I am vacue
sealing my [__] and dropping a [__]
bomb down the
plumbing and that's why it's always an
act of God because oh my Act of God
you're right there's forces happening
there why don't you use just toilet
paper a layer of toilet paper probably
I'll do that that toilet because it's
like it's such a perfect layer it's like
boom wow so that's crazy it'll bag up
and it s sits like a clog it makes so
much it just occurred to me for the
first time today that that might be why
it's man that's why start listening to
me I don't get why it keeps clogging up
I mean I I shove a I shove a um towel
down there every time I take a [__] WIP
my ass for a
towel
it just won't go down first of all it's
a paper towel if you're wondering
whether it's safe to flush paper towels
down the toilet the answer is almost all
almost always no okay almost so this is
like a lupus situation where it's almost
certain that you don't have L regard the
type of paper tow you're using could
cause serious damage to your
plumbing hold on let me ask Chad gbt
wait that's not good enough explanation
well I want a more thorough one I want
to know what this what situations it's
okay can I flush paper towels down the
toilet this is like a thing you learn
when you start pooping don't flush the
towels down the drain yeah I mean I I do
usually don't have paper towels near the
toilet so it's not usually something
that I'm it's not a decision I'm forced
to uh wrestle with it's a routine that's
mainly the office what if you got place
here what if you got to go real bad
though like do do you always put the
paper it it t it's very quick and this
is to prevent splashback yeah it's 100%
accurate it's like right a dry she so
good I haven't been splashed by aswat in
years I mean that is nice but I don't
think it's worth the uh that being said
Dan you can achieve the same thing with
toilet paper it's just a little harder
it's a drier sheet for the
toilet all right let's ask chbt all
right generally it's not generally
emphasize generally not Dev to flush
paper towels down the toilet different
composition toilet paper potential for
clogging stra strain on sewage system
even even if they get past your home's
Plumbing paper toils can cause problems
further down the line okay great now I'm
destroying the city yeah what about a
booster seat so that you're higher up so
that the splash doesn't get you that
doesn't work that seems more dangerous
it'll Splash oh right the velocity guess
I think they did this at clusters they
did a super long and oh God maybe you
should instead just kind of lean so that
your ass is just hovering like just a
millimeter above the water like kind of
just stick your ass down into that would
probably be the best option yeah for
start doing that oh my God I'm going to
die you got to put your legs up more
hold on you got to go like this like got
like you yeah get in there real good I
don't know that for Splash cuz your ass
goes down lower because then then the
poop is just being gently inserted into
the there you go God
I distance and poop will is a constant
it'll the closer you get the smaller you
there's no there's no there's no
loopholes right there's it's a
consistent a equal B there's no there's
no loopholes but there is poop holes
here that's true here I have a I've been
hit by
inspiration and a product called the
poop slide it's a plastic object you
carry with you it looks like a kid slide
kind of has like a nice curve big park
slide and you kind of just if you poop
on that and you slick it so it goes down
nice like with oil keep it lubricated
and I began to slide into him from
behind and you kind of just you poop on
the slide and then it takes a nice
gentle ride down into the water like a
shoehorn like a shoehorn but bigger
right this was my ass basically you want
your poop to look like this not as fast
oh I was just put shopping that damn oh
not as fast not as more more elegant
more elegant now I have a question
create a poop boat is it is all the poop
above the water I don't know honestly
because is there a captain I you know
what let's not get into all the details
because that's what's interesting did
check this out I these are the important
convers the to the paper it's not a
loadbearing weight uh love if that's
what you're wondering Okay so it'll sink
maybe after a couple seconds so here's
what I here's kind of what I'm talking
about I was thinking of something bigger
div board so they call this the splash
guard I was thinking of something bigger
and more robust but this is a good I
like where their heads are at wait so it
would hit this thing and then just kind
of like SL slide off of that into the
water this isn't my idea the diving no
I'm just wondering like how this would
operate like he's going to throw it back
no way right it Springs back it's not a
good design this is not a good
design um okay anyway let's keep on
moving
Dan I'm sorry I'm sorry I I didn't well
I didn't know that we were going to have
this Revelation no it's important and
I'm going to find a real product yeah a
bullseye that you [__] on That's So vile
yeah being real for a second that is
disgusting that's got to be a gag gift
the BSE eye B bowel eye dude I want that
I mean what happens if you succeed now a
turd's just like sitting here this is a
gag this is just a gag there's no way
the bowel
eye that's [__] wicked cool bro you
want one of those Wicked I'd try it out
yeah Lena can you grab a couple of those
for the crew are you sure it's not to
like help a young boy
aim probably it says it's called the
bowels eye oh bowels eye that's
disgusting no bows BS BS eye but it's
meant to be like toilet bow toilet bow
balls no
bowels it's not spelled like bow it's
spelled like bowels balls let me pull it
up
no get your balls up it's it's Bowl's
eye that says BS no that's BS but there
it's bowels
girl there that's the that's way better
it is you know what let's take that to
you're suggesting this as an improved
naming I I thought genuinely it was
called bowel eye I mean it it's just one
letter off here uh I just found the
product
description uh if you struggle to keep
up with the cleaning demands of your
toilet area surrounding maybe it's time
for something new as Innovative Target
for cleaner toilet bowl Bullseye was
developed to eliminate unwanted urine
Splash wait oh for lemonade that's
disgusting it's like a SP that's a real
product get this I can't deal with this
this I have a better idea though this
got to be a joke I get it have you guys
ever seen people jump from like in into
pools like from very far up sure they
from the bottom they bubble so you don't
hit the water as hard so what if you we
put a bubbler at the under underneath
the toilet bubbler that way it will be
no splash and it will be it'll go into
the water
interesting a bubbler cuz the uh when
they do like diving and [__] they bubble
air through the water through the water
so you don't hit it as hard do you want
to carbonate the toilet water carbonate
the toilet water yeah Soda Stream yeah
Soda Stream only like that we just put
one of those in in there all right guys
guys we've talked about [__] enough go
ahead Sam you can close it off we should
do a segment where we all try to make
the best anti-s spashback
product and uh that I mean I'm I'm down
I don't know if that will be cuz we're
all gonna have to like [__] on it right
I have an idea that I think we can
simulate [__] would be good oh we're
doing that Ian you got
that than what do you use you use is the
turd proxy in this that makes a lot more
sense than having to actually [__] on it
because that would be really gross bag
of turd right into our East Coast
viewers I hope you're having a lovely
dinner right now enjoy I can't breath
you're not there you're not there oh I
forgot I'm supposed to plug something a
nightmare um I wanted to tell you guys
speaking of sisters merch the classics
okay I tried to plug it a few weeks ago
it wasn't ready Classics are back we got
a ton of shirts in different colors $20
for the women's classic shrunken tea hey
that's a for shirt Shir so nice it is
beautifully made
engineered um I I'm in love with these
shirts I I wear them pretty much every
day so you you got that one you've got
the classic pocket te this one is I love
it they're all in stock you got um Plum
I'm in love
Navy black and Olive I'm in love and you
know we our idea for this is that we
rotate the colors occasionally when we
restock so the these are the colors of
the season and
um so the shirts are all back the
classic tea is back the classic lumps
this is a pocket tea a long sleeve tea
it's only
$25 yeah then you go down to the hoodies
60 bucks for the for the uh for the
standard hoodie 60 bucks wow we slashed
slashed murdered these prices Wow have
the owners gone
insane and this is super high quality
too it feels so nice I love them it it
it's as good as it gets basically
we we using the same wonderful fabric we
just what we did is we um lowered the
gauge in some cases and what we did is
remove all the kind of little details
and stuff that gets the cost up and
we're also just eating into our our
margin to bring you guys affordable
super high quality Goods that I'm sure
you guys are going to love it's great to
have options $20 beanie $20
hat beanies I can attest to the beanies
the $25 fuzzy bear beanies everyone
loves
those so the thing is yeah you you've
got different tiers here you've got the
$60
hoodie and then this
one this one's zip up so it's 65 cuz
those zippers are really nice they C
you'd be surprised how much zippers cost
man um and
then we've got the women's classic bear
well for men too the classic bear ear
zip hoodie it's got all the features
it's got the ears it's got the zip it's
got the hoodie that's
$70 so it's like DL it's like a DLC
unlocks right it's a $5 DLC for the uh
bear ear yeah I think
so uh but yeah I vouch for all this
stuff I I'm very proud and happy of uh
this line so I hope you guys will check
that out check it
out all right we have somehow been going
for two and a half hours and we have not
gotten to our lead story you're not
there can we finish sister and then go
do
it I I guess I'm not we can do whatever
we want well let me think I I I do want
to go home at a reasonable time so I can
be with the kiddos yeah um yeah let's
finish it out and then let's let's move
on to the Sniper Wolf stuff let me think
about this Sniper Wolf stuff is just not
only is it like great in the sense of
like content for me it's also important
because she is so nuts all right let's
just get into it I'm already setting it
up okay what she's done to Jax film
friend of the show and friend personal
friend
mhm uh frequent guest frankly on this
show M we've talked about his Antics
recently how he created a YouTube
channel called J jacks films it's a
parody of Sniper Wolf who basically
steals people's contents quote unquote
steal
she does reactions of other people's
content with minimal
minimal
reactions and mass uploads it she's
making so many views and so much
money and Jack uh correctly identified
like hey what's going on why is this
being normalized again why is xqc doing
this and nobody cares why is Sniper Wolf
doing this and nobody cares making
literally 10 T of millions of dollars
off other people's
content and
um let me pull up his
channel I think and then she was like
doing personal insults against him and
it all kind of escalated especially from
that I think I forget she was going
crazy on
Twitter
um but the the funny thing here is that
he actually created a real in 2017 a
real entertaining uh product jacket off
where he's basically doing a reaction to
her reaction and in a really wonderful
way it's actually fair
use where hers is
not but um something
happened he hasn't uploaded in three
days it looks like and he he was being
very very consistent here on the Jack's
films Channel what
happened well guys
it gets pretty wild it started here when
Sniper Wolf on Instagram posted a story
that showed the outside of Jack's
house with a caption let's talk like
adults this is
um this is the first
post so she's visiting La I guess she
goes should I visit Jack good idea let's
ask your 12-year-old
audience she yeah how does she know that
even we obviously blurred this but what
is behind the blur is just a
shot of his front house on its Street
fully visible with the address out with
everything and she posted that [__]
let's talk like adult she says and she
doxes
him and everyone was like to say when
you're doxing someone holy [__] let's be
mature about this yeah
I mean like we've all been on the
internet at this point a long time and I
know she has been on the internet for a
very long
time we all know that this is one of the
worst things you can do on the internet
and Sniper Wolf as someone who probably
has some crazed obsessive fans I'm
pretty sure that you
understand uh the risk and the unease
you'd think of doxing somebody despite
how much you might dislike
Jack was actually live while this
happened it's quite interesting to watch
their live reaction and disbelief as
this all unfolds here's Jack playing
with a few of his friends as it
unfolds can y'all look at General real
quick yeah holy
[__] what yeah she really wow oh my
God I didn't really believe it third
round I
that's crazy how would she know I'm
going to all right hold on I
want I'm going to tweet that and say hey
please don't that's creepy your future
so so he's responding first of all to
the first one where she's like should I
go to his house right this isn't even
the docks yet so he this is all
happening live he says please do not do
that that's creepy which is a good
response hold on go look in the
general yeah yeah yeah pause this is
like yeah hold on this is t i I don't
know if it's illegal
I don't know is it illegal to do
that I think broadly no I don't think it
is but obviously it's immoral and
dangerous and you shouldn't but
I there may be some jurisdictions that
have passed laws about it but I think if
you're taking photos where you can see
in the house it can be considered a
breach of privacy I don't know but may
probably it's not illegal frankly you're
right yeah she trying
to I don't know but
like yeah that's that's really sketchy
that's like extremely so sketchy [__]
that how would she know where though how
the [__] does she know where we live
leave me alone [__] I'm sorry oh so
that's Aaron Jack's wife mhm very sweet
um woman who I've had the pleasure of
meeting many times very nice very
awesome she's there
too Aaron that's what I said
[Applause]
right yeah name is
Aaron say something else my wife in this
context oh I I didn't I was looking at
CH gbti sent just in case doxing or
doxing someone which involves revealing
and Publishing private or personal
information is generally considered
illegal dxing can include sharing
information such as person's home
address phone number email etc etc she
did that so the violation of privacy can
have serious legal consequences laws
regarding doxing can vary by country and
even within different regions or States
so the question is what about Los
Angeles yeah so I am seeing it looks
like that there is a doxing law in the
books in California uh doxing is illegal
in California doing so Rises the level
of online
harassment uh doxing or dropping
docks uh refers to publishing personal
information uh with the intent to
identify them with the intent to
identify them see that's where it gets
tricky
because no well Jack is a public figure
he he's attempting to I I think anyway I
think there's something there and I'm
pretty sure he's going to he's going to
explore yeah it definitely as he should
yeah yeah she's she's in the house right
now Jack shut
up five minutes ago posted wait what
she's literally right outside your oh my
God this is happening right [__] now
call the [__]
police wait what like call the police no
there's a video she's outside your house
right now what the [__] holy it's like a
it's like a nightmare before Elm Street
with a sniper
wolf Jason's outside your door comound
the name of two movies in a really
interesting way but I knew what you
meant Nightmare on Elm Street you got
write Jason yeah Freddy Fred right I
know I know but they have collabed
together yeah there have been collabs
yeah yeah Freddy V
Jason uh so I'm seeing uh I found the
California Penal Code it says every
person who with the intent to place
another person in reasonable fear for
his or her safety or the safety of
others in immediate family by means of
electronic communication device all this
is sounding like what she did yeah uh
and without consent of the other person
and for the purpose of imminently
causing that other person unwanted
physical contact injury or harassment by
third
party right so basically to encourage
like her fans to do something about it I
think that's right on that's a that's a
perfect should be publishing email
hyperlinks make available downloading
personal identifying
information a digital image of another
person trying to see she did it she did
it yeah yeah I mean it sounding sound
like she violated legal
violation yeah you know what I mean he
could probably sue her for a
nice a nice sum how do you not know that
that's going to blow up in your face is
what baffles me like what is her thought
process she thinks that this will make
her look good she's thinking that she's
been stealing people's content for a
decade and made like $50 million off it
so she never been held accountable for
anything so she thinks
that right all gravy baby
yeah she got to be off the deep end with
it because that is wild if not drug
induced I can't see someone doing that
in a sober State of Mind unless you're
just losing it unless she's still high
several days have passed and she's still
defending it but let's let's continue
the
video on her story minutes ago my God
she is she's outside our house [__]
record this right now [__] you yeah I
mean disbelief no this is [__] [__]
that another Creator could be so dumb
like cuz there's certain rules right
guys we
know like you don't dox people no that
that is
huge
privacy she's right there so much else
there's so much wrong with that no I'm
not getting out dude [__]
that if it was Texas I think he could
kill
her huh if it was Texas I think he could
her castle doctrine bro I think she'd
have to I think she would have to
probably approach the house to uh for
that she did she dude I'm telling you
castle doctor man we'll work we'll
figure out oh well we don't we don't
have none of that in California
so what the [__] not saying it's the
right thing to do I just uh you're just
saying from a legal standpoint I don't
think that that would be the case in
California it might be in Texas
unironically yeah yeah she should not
have shown up to his house that's
crazy her call the cops and show them
the Instagram story hold on I'm going to
go
out do not do not go out there all right
hold on should we I'm going to end this
um but yeah end this stream thank you
for coming out um but we this is this
is this was one of her
stories she said Jack film abruptly ends
his live when he finds out no she didn't
why is it oh this is just a screenshot I
see yeah yeah that's one we already
showed okay so that's
insane yeah and there's more
um this has led to some of snipers
insane followers leaking their address
of course I mean
obviously um this person just keeps
posting it everywhere mhm Let's
see we blurred it but it's just a
straight up picture of the house during
the day he wants clout because he's so
broke and going bald that he needs a
wig that's all dude got
him um more people where is it where
they sniper had this really insane take
where she's like it's not like it's
private all I did was Google Jack film's
address right right like further doing
it essentially here a follow-up post
between the two of them number six uh
here's a follow-up post of uh Leia is
her name I think I feel silly calling
her Sniper Wolf I
mean she just
Leia Sniper Wolf just docks me on
Instagram creepy gross violating what
you do is discusting SK content and
stock YouTubers
at YouTube demonetizes dangerous Creator
or just get her off your platform she
posted on IG right outside our home and
deleted it first of all Jack I love you
rookie mistake don't ever tag YouTube
you got to tag team
YouTube oh I see if you tag YouTube it
will go into the void no one will ever
ever ever ever ever see it I see but
team YouTube the guys who run that
account man are slick they're quick okay
uh but regardless I sure they saw it
there's been a lot of conversating about
it she literally posted a video outside
her house for all of her 5.6 million
followers see then delet it in what
Universe do you think that's okay and
what reality do you live in where this
kind of behavior is Justified it's time
to get her off the platform she's no
longer a silly creator that steals
content T he she's a creep that stalks
and threatens her critics now [__] that
time to get off YouTube I got to say
um that I fully agree I
mean what do you do I feel that YouTube
does need to intervene because I mean
it's one of their biggest creators it's
somebody that YouTube has directly
endorsed numerous times and they're
recently
recently uh from not a great look chat
has a good idea instead of
sniper s s Sniper Wolf we'll just call
her SS the SS the SS showed up outside
of Jack's
house um yeah the thing is even as
recently they they're putting her on
panels they're posting about her and um
that's really [__] crazy uh she
responded this creep has been harassing
me for months then plays victim saying I
threaten him when I just wanted to talk
to him I have no intelligent it's so sad
when people have to constantly create
drama to pay their bills I I genuinely
don't you're [__] idiot know if she
really believes that um I have a hard
time believing that she's not that dense
she knows what she did
uh but either way if you're that dumb
then let's also get you off the
internet um you know and to say he's
threatening her we're familiar with this
people who are not familiar with it
might misinterpret that he is for sure
not harassing her uh I would I would say
I mean you know what maybe he he is
harassing her probably I guess in the
technical sense but like it's warranted
I mean I mean he is harassing her but
that's not always a bad
thing I mean sometimes people need to be
harassed like like for example the
Senate let's I'm and I use that like
let's harass our Representatives 100%
call your representative here here's the
definition subject to aggressive
pressure or intimidation well so he's
not intimidating her but he's he is push
I'd say exerting pressuring her I
wouldn't say aggressively I would say in
a very healthy sense he's playing Bingo
there's no there's no threat of physical
harm yeah I don't think it quite Rises
to harass I mean brutally and
consistently
critiquing yes I think it matches
calling the representatives that was a
very very nice we all harass
representative people at times and
obviously sometimes it's warrant and
sometimes it's
not you know like for example sometimes
um
it is very funny are you see what was
just
dropped Zach is back here dying at
this boogie I can help with the security
DET well if to be fair he does he was
the victim of doxing as
well yeah know so he knows the man knows
oh my God been
[Laughter]
around that's a boogie dub I guess it's
a rare very rare a rare dub but it is a
dub and our boy went out with strapped
to meet his
doctor you
know and we love that for him did like
shoot a warning shot too he did did heed
the gun he got in trouble for he got in
trouble he he he got jail yeah he got
arrested for shooting a shot off in did
he shoot it in the air that's czy boom
boom yo that's not cool crazy he shot
three times that's I think it was just
once um yeah I it's this weird situation
where like I think I don't know the
rules of I don't remember what state
he's in or whatever but it it assuming
they have the castle doctrine thing I
think he got in more more trouble for
shooting into the air than he would have
shooting the person awesome at his house
which is very cool it's a nightmare
close to a school zone too yeah a
reckless discharging of a weapon in
public that's not a good thing killing
killing someone on your property is a
great thing Bear game that's cast Bear
game he basically got a fine for missing
if you if you got a fine for missing you
guys are not American and don't know
what I'm talking about in a few super
conservative States there's this thing
called the castle doctrine that says
anyone that approaches your property
basically is a very open season open
open uh loose law that states that you
can [__] kill them if you reasonably
believe that you're you're in danger and
again reasonably believe you're in
danger is something you can apply I mean
Boogie could easily make that argument
MH and so could jack if he wanted to
shoot her if he was in
Texas well I hey maybe just shared I
guess California does have a version of
the castle doctrine I I have a feeling
that uh they're probably a little bit
more strict in the interpretation what's
our what's our castle doctrine so Jack
knows his rights for next California's
castle doctrine is legal principle in
which residents are presumed to have a
reasonable fear of death right so that's
the difference is like you you have to
reasonably think like you're about to
die um if an intruder forcibly enters
the home that's the other thing they
would have to actually enter the
premises so you have to you have to
think that they were going to kill you
and be in your house this one is just
you're in danger and they're on your
they're on your they've crossed the
property line right it's awesome that's
America so anyway uh she is really
moronic uh for that she says I have no
ill intentions this is Jack's response
Sniper Wolf you showed up to our home
tonight and filmed it for 5 million
Instagram followers that's called doxing
the harassing you claim I've been doing
is documenting recent examples of you
stealing creators content stealing jokes
and failing to provide transformative
commentary obviously struck a nerve but
wow docy me was not on my bingo card
there's no reality you're in the right
and of course Jack is right he's always
right always
King when has he ever been wrong frankly
never she responded 400 videos online
[__] on someone but wanting to talk
IRL goes too far Modern Men are a joke
again
you could reach out privately the why
that doesn't need to happen on your
Instagram story first of
all the insinuation that that's what
happened she's not are she that dense is
she that
dumb she's not she's like she's bearing
the lead as they
say which is that you took a picture of
his house with the address and posted
online I just wanted to talk I was just
trying to tell you that I'm here here
ready to
talk I was just trying to polite you let
you know where I am outside so you can
meet me to talk accusing me of doxing is
defamation oh shut the [__] up what let
me talk I have no idea how to dox oh
dude she's not that dumb she's been on
the internet for I don't know she's
meing I think I have no idea how to
docks that's like what my grandma would
say how do you do a
docks he literally posted his address on
Google and said I threatened him and
doxed him I what how do you post
something on Google so going on uh she's
posting more defending her doxing him
this is obsessive behavior is this
really the only way you can get views on
YouTube don't you have a wife that I
don't get you can unmute this it's muted
top right she's insinuating he wants to
[__] her like get a grip
lady he's criticizing you oh I didn't I
don't know what else that I didn't
interpret it that way but maybe you're
right I I don't know how else other to
interpret maybe that he's supposed to be
VY just like being yeah that just don't
you don't you have better things to be
doing which he literally was playing
with his wife when she docked him and
put her in danger I think I think she's
implying that the amount of attention
he's giving her should threaten his
wife's right confidence in the
relationship and so she was posting all
of this after the incident yeah yeah
yeah yeah this is all it's like listen
like I wouldn't agree with her but like
if she if she decided to pop off Jack
and post stuff like this she's well
within her rights to be like what the
[__] stop making videos about me or
whatever th% yeah but but doing this to
uh try and um deflect criticism for what
she did is that's pretty crazy um you
said this was a video oh here how do I
unmute it the top right there's a little
oh there's little Jesus Christ tin from
me every single video for the past few
months has been about me and it's just
like [__] on me and then his streams
this dude is just like lowkey harassing
me like should I get a restraining order
you just showed up his house TI what are
you talking about if anyone's getting a
restraining order it's the person that
showed up and doxed them and I mean yeah
if you did get a restraining order that
would probably be preferable to Jack as
well which means that you cannot go near
him right so yes let's get the
restraining order going
theast few months has been about me and
it's just like [__] on me and then
his streams pretty incredible this dude
is just like lowkey harassing me like
should I get a restrain her I can't
pause it no he is harassing her how you
g he's highkey harassing I still don't
think really Rises to the level of
harassment I mean not like the the legal
or not the legal good kind of harassment
yeah we all we all um agitate and activ
at uh certain entities and people at
time you know for example like my my
power went out and I called the power
company like 10 times asking where's the
power I'm I'm harassing them they say
stop harassing me I said I want my
[__] power back I feel so powerful so
she says lowkey and I wish you would
just amend her language to be more
accurate he's iy uh harassing
you but with a very uh good reason
Justified
harassment she ends this with saying
should I get a restraining order well
one of us showed up to the other's house
tonight and it wasn't me right team
YouTube those are my people they
responded we don't allow harmful
Behavior like threats and doxing this
resource has more info about our
harassment and
policy um the [__] could you please look
into this Jack said so I think they
acknowledged it let's keep going I sent
a video this is how Sniper Wolf expected
him to answer the door it's time stamped
right you guys remember this oh my God
you're you're Sniper
[Music]
Wolf this is how she expected him to
react you must be Mia oh yeah I I'm
sorry oh my gosh look like this right
now where that you're totally fine I
don't know leave me alone Dar and I you
still got it open I think it open twice
somehow oh it's playing in Discord
that's crazy that's
crazy I can't CH and you're not here
really hit that one uh she made a joke
about the situation the following day
she's she said she was in LA for a shoot
maybe she was doing another Dar man I
hope so that's the she was sniping she's
doing a uh Darman video about respecting
people's privacy shoot the son of a
[__] this is her her sister I think she
says we show up to your house what do
you do sister looks
scared we show up to your house what do
you
do again she just she thinks
that it's just cute it's just a quirky
little thing I think she genuinely is
like we're so hot who wouldn't want to
see us at their
house like I genuinely think when I walk
past someone's house yeah they're like
what excuse me what guy would be angry
about us showing up at their house don't
you have a wife
right or you are
undatable I think no you're not
undatable I don't know anything about
you I won't go that far everyone's
deserving of Love even
her that's that's too extreme it's just
a just a minor doxing
situation just a minor D yeah
she uh uh sniper her sister is
encouraging fans to look up his
address uh continue to harass and dox
him pretty incredible this is her sister
I guess the real Soley G now oh no no
sorry this is a reporter who's uh
reporting on it now Sniper Wolf sister
encouraging fans to look up his address
in addition to confirming that they were
100% there to harm him here is uh her
comments not you defending doxing that's
just sad someone commented she responded
she didn't dox anyone dumb ass Google
Jack's film address lol anyone can see
it they're dumb they so dumb is is that
what she meant when she said he posted
his address to go that's why I was
saying like wink wink like oh my God
totally the internet doesn't work that
that way and you work on it you should
know they're so dumb she doesn't realize
how much she's incriminating herself by
saying that it's
crazy uh damn does he not know how to
fight or something she said
what
what yeah what you wanted him to go out
there and fight her yeah you wanted to
throw down as someone who was recently
ducked this is insane well well she's
she's saying that she was looking for a
violent
confrontation in a sense yeah right
which definitely would uh that
definitely would go against her not look
good in courtroom um damn she these
these people are
lost holy [__]
oh God that's disturbing cam this is so
cursed here is uh this is what Sniper
Wolf wish
happened don't you know how to come
outside and
fight make my
day go ahead make my day take a step on
my property I gu I dare you and wait for
the wolf who should be coming directly I
fired three bullets in the air the
question is
you send in the wo do you feel lucky you
send in the
wo oh man wow crazy
story uh let's see another immature
response from her sister glad to know
the whole family is moronic runs in the
family clearly hi sisters in addition to
reaching out to YouTube be sure to
report them for this Behavior based on
the action it's clear that she's heading
down a dangerous path it will no doubt
cause serious issues going forward she
said suck my nuts which to be fair is
probably the least problem think I mean
that's fine she should have started and
with that and then kept that energy yeah
these nuts exactly
mom uh Jack's or Jack's wife Aaron
tweeted at Team YouTube and got quite a
lot of traction on her tweet I'm happy
to say dear uh YouTube and she tagged
team YouTube that's good I am not a
Creator but my husband is tonight Sniper
Wolf came to my home posted on her
Instagram for all to see and tried to
instigate a confrontation enough to
worry about what about what she as one
of your favorite
creators you don't have to worry about
what she as one of your favorite
creators uh they said appreciate
characters anyway team report uh Team
YouTube said appreciate the report we're
passing this on so they are aware of it
so that was on Saturday I was seeing
from the time stamp I mean YouTube are
they all gone during the weekend uh the
people that actually make decisions like
this so from my experience almost
everybody has gone on the weekend and
that's one of the things I've always
laughed at them for like just hire more
people to work on the weekend like I
told them well they're just a they're
just a scrappy little startup company I
this is response to that I say well
that's a good thing nobody posts on the
weekend so you guys are fine
yeah so stupid can y just hire more
people you
know I'm sure there's people that would
love to be there on the
weekend well in some interesting
development sniper Wolf's G fuel page
seems to have been
pulled HOH we've been down this
nightm been in this road she's telling
herself nightmare a nightmare you really
cross the line
Jack when you're
nightmare
nightmare another just to highlight the
me insane this is a nightmare just to
highlight the absurdity of
YouTube they are constantly propping her
up here she is doing a keynote uh speech
at VidCon this happen is happening in
June no no no it just happened last June
wait what month is it oh oober year yeah
this was like three or four months ago
it was in June this year well she didn't
she hadn't done she hadn't doxed or
threatened anybody then right but but
still her type of
content but I agreed the her type of
content should not
be paraded around like I saw a tweet
from YouTube tweeted out one of our
videos and was like we love Sniper Wolf
like just like a little while AG that
was sort of one of the main instigators
of Jack starting down this path yes this
is the tweet I think you're talking
about oh thank you
AB yeah you're right jack saw this and
got pissed Sniper Wolf is the creator of
our dreams um
readers added a community note Sniper
Wolf recently docks Jack films which is
in clear violation of YouTube's
Community guidelines
uhoh you're not there not there yeah
they're in a they're in a spot now so
here they wrote about her Sniper Wolf
has created her online fan base the wolf
pack around her gaming skills cosplay
and reaction videos you sending the
W that is a good that is a good name for
a fan base the wolf pack and wait for
the wolf who should become bring out the
Wolves where my pack
at you sending the wolf I'm sure that's
what her audience sounds
like uh so friendly reminder that yeah
yeah yeah so that also here's the Tweet
we opened this
already but um here is the tweet in
question that's that's basically it oh
he put a video up let's watch this
yeah it's pretty short last night Sniper
Wolf a massive YouTuber showed up
outside of our home recorded a video of
our home and then posted it to her 5.6
million it sounds farfetch to the point
of being like he's got to be
exaggerating that's literally what
happened Instagram followers goting me
with the line let's talk like adults in
my 17 years you got Jack never say what
you seeing reflection in his I think he
has four ring lights dude this man's a
professional I'm telling you you hear
he's been in the game for 17 years he
knows what's up the light is balanced on
that face and he has filled in really
nicely I'll say absolutely absolutely
got a nice F there could work I think it
maybe a little bluish on the um the
color balance it be a stylistic choice
though it's making his Hazel pop true
right those Hazel are something man from
one Hazel boy to another I love that
he's wearing a headset
though G that's a gamer move that's a
Pro Gamer
move someone come to my home and vaguely
threaten me Sniper Wolf needs to be
deplatformed in this exact moment she
turned from a mere content Thief to
someone who doxes and stalks her critics
to everyone that's reached out to us
thank you we're fine we're just a little
shaken up but mainly we feel violated we
no longer feel safe in our own home
because we're dealing with someone who
genuinely thinks they're in the right
for a stalking me and B posting our home
to her massive audience what a
disgusting abuse of clout that is this
is irresponsible at best and flat out
dangerous at worst poti illegal YouTube
needs to step in and take action
if this goes unpunished then it sets a
terrifying precedent that you can dox
and stalk your critics so long as you
have a big YouTube audience if she truly
wanted to talk with me she could have
done so through many other means but
there's one thing you don't do you do
not show up at someone's house that's
simply a line you do not cross and even
worse posting a picture of it there is
zero justification for this man speaking
she claims in her story that I've been
harassing her no Sniper Wolf I've not
been harassing you at all in my videos
on Jud Jack films I've been critiquing
her non-transformative commentary I
point out cases of content theft and
freebooting and I credit the creators
she steals from I've been critical of
her content but that does not equate to
harassment what is
I guess we disagree on the definition of
harassment I'm saying it's good that's
what they that's what I'm I'm Pro you're
using it in like a colloquial sense yeah
I'm Pro in this case you know I think
it's good that he's harassing her okay
harassment in the proverbial sense not
in the legal sense legal harassment is
bad yeah legal harassment is bad legal
legal har like under the definition
under the legal defal harassment no by
the legal definition of harassment I
suit you're saying the legal definition
of harassment oh my God no
X God never
never you
know harassment is coming to our home
sharing it for Millions to see and
taunting me to come out YouTube needs to
take Swift action and ban her from the
platform ASAP and the same goes for
Instagram speaking of Sniper Wolf is
already actually right about Instagram
cuz she posted that [__] to that
platform light of the situation as if
stalking someone is a quirky thing to do
no one should feel unsafe in their own
home what' I do stop itching your tattoo
stop oh no it's like fully healed
already is it yeah okay I was just put I
was just applying the um oh you were
putting something on I thought I'm sorry
I thought you were picking at it and I
was like no no no it's it's basically
all fully healed there's just a little
it's all scabbed it's all peeled off uh
it's peeled it's just yeah yeah yeah
it's it's like totally healed pretty
much oh healed it's just there's a few
parts during the dark spots where the
skin is just has a little more like
regeneration to do but mhm it's fine now
okay all right beauti it's a done deal
it's a done deal
baby thanks to Sniper Wolf my wife and I
now do so YouTube please do the right
thing and get off the platform anyone
who weaponizes their fan base like she
did hold on let's get a good shot of
those ring lights I see three did you
see one with four yeah there there was
another part where there was one bigger
one there oneing to rule them all there
you go see I think that's that's the one
ring and then those are the three Elven
Rings Lord of the Rings he is the Lord
of the Rings Lord of the Ring lights
Lord of the Ring light shall not pass
iconic iconic Jack as always so YouTube
secret pleas do the right thing and get
her off the platform anyone who
weaponizes their fan base like she did
does not deserve a space
here okay pretty serious message and
frankly if YouTube doesn't do anything
that is
really really
unbelievable I know they love her they
love her Revenue they love the views and
they love the demographic probably of
like kids well on it c yeah exact I mean
her content is totally like yeah it's
like safe like oh it's it's safe for
anyone to watch yeah it's it's
familyfriendly like and that's why it's
so stupid if she
just not docks to somebody she's got a
great thing going on like a really great
thing yeah it's just like such a dumb
thing to do my God as far as far as I
can tell if I go to her Channel I don't
think his campaign against her has
impacted her views at all I'm sure her
comment section is like a it's probably
all [__] up but in terms of
views excuse me man what so we're only
using the
toe uh that she's still pulling crazy
yeah it's the same as it was N9 days ago
1.6 million 900 1.2 8 1 million she was
posted one hour ago by the way she's in
La she she preloads this it's so easy
dude she probably works one day of the
month just yeah you could just 30 videos
[__] it knock out a [__]
ton yep that's a good gig right there
why yeah why like who cares if Jack
films is making fun of you it's not
affecting her her uh bottom line here
yeah let's see what the comments are
like friends Hello friends it's she's
got the g- fuel in the back M have to
get rid of that me and today is d man
don't call attention to that right
that's what I did to keemstar yeah class
people said I went after his sponsors my
God man right uh but actually uh don't
listen the thing about gfuel is though
that there is lead in it and I only [__]
with gamer sub gamer
sub and when I say lead I want to be
clear it's it's it's probably a
negligible amount of lead right it's in
California we we have this uh I I guess
regulation or whatever you call it where
like any place that any Trace Amounts of
carcinogens can be found needs to have a
sign on the front of it saying uh this
place has things that can cause cancer
or whatever yeah um and it's written in
such a broad way that literally every
[__] business in the state of
California has one of those signs in
front of it didn't really end up being
that useful yeah it's right there yeah
see that everywhere I'm at Starbucks and
they're like everywhere there are things
in this building will give you cancer
yeah because there of course the it's
really so dumb very stupid and it's
about like [__] that is like a
construction material that you would
have to eat or like dumb [__] it's just
not happening but anyway um I can't
sleep it's a
nightmare
nightmare can we just appreciate how
great Sniper Wolf is at creating more
and more for herself instead of trying
to eliminate it really someone to live
up to can we appreciate Sniper Wolf
always managed to promote criminal
Behavior okay so she's actually not yeah
well this I mean this this the first one
since the incident that's this was just
an hour
ago yeah I don't yeah might I don't
think it's the first one though
since uh but okay uh she did post one
yesterday too actually so
yeah um see what the like ratio is
like here we go she's like a b day
Bloody Mary not as bad as I would have
expected but I guess there's still time
eh yeah I mean the the interesting
nature of her content is simply just
that it's just recommendation and next
play fodder that's all it is MH and
that's why YouTube loves her it's
appropriate for all young kids watch it
because they don't know any better they
just want to watch the compilation of
funny videos which we all love right and
uh YouTube can just feed that [__] to
any body you know what I mean that's why
there's so little engagement it's just
recommendation fodder like that girl is
serving at the Leisure of the YouTube
Empire they [__] built that nation of
hers
uh so that's basically that and I really
hope that YouTube does do something cuz
it'd be pretty wild not
to so I am team Jack film all the
way it would be such such bad PR for
them if they don't do
anything it's not it's not just anybody
it's like again it's somebody that they
like straight up are like yes this is
the face of YouTube right uhhuh why does
that always happen like they won't ever
let me be the face of YouTube well but
like I'm not gonna there's no surprises
with me or well
in a way you know what I mean like I'm
not well maybe maybe part fun maybe
there are this is actual that's his
actual face I'm so sorry but maybe the
lesson is that you know why not me
because she's going to [__] up too you
know PewDiePie was the face of YouTube
and God bless him right that man dropped
an end bomb on a live stream on a
YouTube live stream they don't have the
best track record do they no and then
the other chosen ones were Jake and
Logan Paul they were like the golden CH
children Charles was a golden child oh
yeah the suicide forest was like a month
after YouTube Rewind where it was all
Paul it was like 50% Paul
Brothers David do yeah do was a darling
James may be glad that they didn't pick
you cuz this this does seem like a curse
that they put on people well they got to
kind of just embrace it at this point
well and then the other people that
weren't controversial that I can think
of who are like former Darlings is like
gella
and
Hannah there's a whole bunch of oh
Hannah
Hart and then what's who's the other guy
that looks like Ellen Tyler Oakley Tyler
Oakley I remember him so like the other
thing is that I don't
think they have a very engaged
audience right so it's a curse I think
to Al who is touched by it people was
saying Shane Dawson too Shane speaking
of did you see yesterday he dropped a
conspiracy video with Jeffree Star are
it literally felt like we were in 2018
again he's he's desperate he wants to go
back yeah I actually wonder I want to
see how that performs that's what I was
just going to do girl I want to go oh my
God on the same page we're reading the
same book Dawson Casey survived it he's
the only one you're right Casey survived
it but we did get K-pop
y'all that's fine we love K-pop it's
been one day and it's
973k so it's pretty good that's good
views but it ain't what it used to be I
don't know yeah you're right about that
you know who YouTube stood by and I feel
confident saying he can do no wrong and
as a perfect angel and will never be in
a controversy go ahead Mark ass brownley
yeah I was about to say that oh man he
is such a good guy he's a [__] King
shout out he will never let us down so
maybe maybe it's not so much the curse
it's just the some people just they
can't deal with it they cannot deal with
the
uh pressure this possible it's a lot
right to go and become that famous
especially when YouTube they feature you
in these YouTube ruines which they
stopped will get like 300 million views
plus someone had like a billion
views Will Smith got it the worst he he
got SLA
he yeah his wife cheated on him because
of it keep my wife name out your [__]
mouth by the way there was interesting
developments with that oh God they
weren't even together and actually they
were fully
separated and and Jada was talking about
it and again this this woman is her sole
existence to humiliate
will I was so blown away by some of
these headlines she goes I wasn't sure
if it are we sure it's not like just
like clickbait cuz some of it was so
like oh my God why would she say that
it's all real everything you've heard is
on
video dude yeah she was like saying like
she was shocked when it happened and she
was surprised
and is her soulmate she says I was
shocked and surprised because we weren't
even together I didn't understand why he
was calling me his wife that's so crazy
something that [__] up his reputation
for a very long time and she's like that
was so [__] up that he did that I mean
it was let's be honest but it didn't
really work for anyone I don't think she
she did not seem to enjoy that yeah no
someone's got she was like I'm not with
him also and obviously I remember you
you were not thrilled about him doing
that but you recall that there were lots
of people that were happy that he did
that because it's like yes standing up
for his black wife and like making jokes
about black women's hair is not you know
there was like a lot of angles of why
people were appreciative of him standing
up for her wife his wife and then for
her to just be like oh I didn't care
about any of that we weren't even
together it's just like girl all these
people were like on your team like what
are you doing you doing the only thing
to say his ass as if she's like I
appreciated that very much she right and
she did not and that's what I was
wondering she should have played that up
for him like I was touched that he stood
up for me stood up for me yeah exactly I
mean then then he could have got at
least
some but yeah no he's he's he's fully
thrown under the bus somebody uh a
member thank you to Erica 19mon member
thank you she said and this is very true
to be fair Ethan is the only one with a
perfectly rated
apology it's true
so I don't know if YouTube takes that
into consideration [__] my mouth but
there you it is it is good to know that
it's not a total curse you've got Casey
you've got Mark ass
brownley there's got to be more Emma
Chamberlain was a darling and she's
doing very very very well she's very
professional very in the fashion scene
she's crushing it amazing uh who else
who else made it did they back Bill
Burnham like that I don't think so I
think he was I don't I don't know that
was a long time ago [__] yeah true Mr
Beast maybe Mr Beast hasn't he's got
time still yeah he's still got give him
give him some time yeah GM Jenna
Marbles is definitely someone that I and
a lot of people support unfortunately
that she just felt she had to get off
the internet so I don't know if that
counts as a curse or not I miss her but
in my opinion she never did anything
wrong in modern modern days Good
Mythical Morning Rett and Link come
on they can do no wrong ever marz
brownley and Rett and Link in a room
together World pieces resolved mhm I
should probably stop calling him Mark
ass brownley because it's been so long
since that YouTube Rewind people might
not know everyone knows what I'm
referring to and just think I'm calling
him Mark ass that's a Will Smith Will
Smith ISM Zach grab the mark ass
brownley so that you can give the
context when when we say that just seem
like a dick saying his name wrong on
purpose fortnite he went Mark ass
brownley fortnite
ninja ninja he was more of a twitch
darling than a YouTube darling he was in
the rewind though man he hadza Koshi was
driving the bus right
yeah I mean by the way PewDiePie to say
he's curs though he he still enjoyed a
tremendous amount of success all the way
even to today he's B basically just
retired he's like he's like did YouTube
and he's done doing so I don't think
he's been cursed I don't think that's
to oh [__] I got to watch that before we
leave hold on one last thing how long
we' been going down uh
3:25 damn we didn't get to watch the new
the Vampire Hunter
either good stuff for Wednesday true we
didn't talk [__] either yeah let's
save it I'll save it ab's like please
please for love of God it's the Logan
stuff we can't even show anyways
right we'll take a look we'll F we'll
talk about it
okay can't s when you're
not
nightmare not there great now that's
going to be stuck in my head too in
addition to the uh to the Maga We Are
the World guys we're done we're done
thank you for watching thank you
everyone who is you know being
supportive of all the [__] that we've
been dealing with I appreciate that and
I will also say I don't know if I said
it but the comments on the YouTube video
itself were very wholesome encouraging
for the most part so you said at the
beginning yeah so that was good but
anyway thank you to all the members we
had no sponsors today so this is brought
to brought To Us by you are supportive
sponsors who we love speaking of our uh
members SL sponsors whatever tomorrow
I'll be doing doing my see you next
Tuesday for our lovely
members uh Cameron just be prepared to
change your uh SIM card okay sounds good
well I think I would like to try and do
our little experimental uh setup uh with
the button so we may we may have a
safety net tomorrow marz brownley there
it is marz brownley do it again marz
brownley marcass
brownley shout out to Blizzard his name
is Marcus shout out huh or Maris it's
Mar marus Marquez brownley it's just
Marcus I think there was a Twist to it I
think it wasn't Mark oh maybe I'm wrong
I think it was Mark well anyway it's not
Mark ass it's definitely not Mark that's
the one that I know Marquez
brownley uh anyway see members tomorrow
Dan and Ela have
colluded they're trying to insert the
button into the members episode
and we're Brown we're going to try that
tomorrow but regardless love you guys so
much thank you all for being here thank
you for your support thank you for your
viewership and thank you for being you
and you're so [__] cool if you like
this show like just think about that
think about how D you dumb idiots right
there that don't like this show but
you're one of the good ones that does
and how [__] cool is that for
you so
cool mark as
[Music]
brownley